Oh, my box is still back there.
Give me a sec.
Sorry, I forgot about my little booster seat right there.
The cookie's so tight.
Oh my god.
I was so ready to start on time.
You don't understand.
And then, I was ready to start on time.
I was like, Cookie, wake up.
Cookie's ready for her 9 to 5.
She's gonna be on time.
She's dead inside because it's 12.30 in the morning.
P.M., morning, P.M., same thing.
I was like, it's time.
I'm ready.
I'm ready to stream.
And then, Cookie had to deal with technology problems because, for some reason, I was not showing up on screen.
And I was like, why?
Well, I was, but it wasn't tracking.
It wasn't showing me moving.
And I was like, why is Cookie dead?
I'm not dead.
I'm right here.
And then, I was watching a YouTube video, and I was so confused.
I was like, I didn't change anything.
Why Cookie not move?
Cookie dead?
How dead if I'm here?
And then, I was like, okay, let me check my IP address.
Maybe that's why.
And then, for some reason, my IP address is... I don't know if it is different or my phone reset itself, but it can't because it's the same as the PC.
When I input the numbers, what do the numbers mean?
And so, I changed the numbers to fit the IP address I have that's on my PC, and it worked.
And then, I was like, wow, IP address different?
Is that possible?
Who's hacking me?
Did Cookie get hacked?
How IP address different?
I was like, Cookie will worry about that later.
Cookie has to stream.
That is future not Croaky problem.
That is anime girl Doki problem.
That ain't Croaky's problem.
Cro need not worry.
Cro just play video games.
I'm here now, guys.
Okay, I guess Croaky will give life update.
I wrote life.
Guys, okay, so, I found out that I might be unintentionally making my health worse in ways.
And then, so, you might be wondering, what do you mean by that, Croaky?
What do you mean?
So, you guys know I have a humidifier.
So, sometimes I turn to use it.
And I found out a couple of days ago.
I found out by a couple of days, I mean like three days ago.
I found out you're not supposed to use tap water with a humidifier.
Croaky didn't know.
And then, because I was like, I'm going to...
So, I was talking to my friend and I was like, I'll be right back.
I'm going to refill my humidifier.
And my friend was like, with like boil water, right?
I was like, no.
No, does it matter?
And they're like, yes.
Croaky's been using tap water this entire time.
In the bedroom.
And her humidifier is in the bedroom.
And sometimes in the PC room in the office.
So, for those who are like, what's wrong with tap water?
So, apparently, if you use tap water, it also, there's like minerals in tap water.
And like, it also, it like, not good.
Because the minerals and whatever chemical, I don't fucking know.
I don't remember the exact thing.
It like, also goes up into the air.
So, you're breathing in many minerals as well with the humidifier.
And also, like, that's how you get mold.
So, um, yeah.
And also, apparently, it affects like, it affects, it like, destroys the machine quicker.
It deteriorates it quicker by using tap water.
So, tap water, not good.
And I've had this humidifier for a couple of months now.
And I'm pretty sure I've used it at least 20 times, if not more.
Oh, no, most definitely.
No, yeah, no, most definitely more than 20.
Yeah.
Croaky here for a good time.
I should have boiled.
So, now, but, now, now I boiled the water.
I think it's still, I think it's still fixable, guys.
I think, I think my body is still fixable, guys.
I think we can still fix it.
It's not too late.
It's never too late.
I might have breathed in a lot of minerals, but it's never too late, guys.
It's, it's, it's fixable.
There's a lot of things that has happened to my body, but it's always fixable, guys.
It's, it's, it's always fixable.
Never, yeah, never too late, right?
It's never too late.
So, Croaky learned.
Croaky learned three days ago.
Now, Croaky is hoping that I can still fix it.
I can still fix it.
It's still possible.
I can fix it.
Thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you, thank you.
Next scene, thank you for the super chat.
I can fix your dookie at herself.
It's still fixable, guys.
It's never too late.
It's, I, I boiled the water now, guys.
My body now knows.
Body now knows.
So, it's okay.
It's always still okay, somehow.
So, yeah, that's story time.
That is story time.
Now, we all know.
You may need distilled, not just... Wait, what do you mean boiled ain't enough?
Wait, what do you... Wait, what do you mean by that?
Boiled water is not enough.
So, my friend lied?
My friend said boiled water will fix it.
What, what do you mean?
I've been using boiled water the last three days.
What do you... It's okay.
Now, I know it's distilled water.
I can still fix it.
It's okay.
What's three more days worth of minerals gonna do to me anyway?
Guys, what's... Guys, what's three more days worth of minerals gonna do to this body?
It's just three days.
Now, I fix it.
Now, I fix it with distilled water.
Alright, okay, anyway.
So, that's life update.
I'll update you guys later if the... I'll update you guys later if the minerals do anything.
I didn't even say it's never... Yeah, it's never too late to change.
Exactly, paladin.
Also, boiling water helps with distilled... Okay, yeah, guys.
Now, I know.
So, my friend lied.
Okay, anyway.
Today, we're gonna be continuing Death's Door.
We're gonna play until we finish it, obviously.
So, does anyone remember I used controller or not?
It's been a while, guys.
Okay, we actually need to look at, like, the... Like, what... Apparently, my... I also read that apparently my IP address has changed and stuff, which is pretty freaky.
I didn't know that.
I didn't know they could do that.
That's fucking weird.
But now, I know.
Now, I know.
It changes.
Alright, was I using... Okay, I was using controller.
That's good to know.
Thank you, guys.
Wait, what?
Which one am I?
Well, not... It's not... Okay, restart Steam.
Give me back my... My Steam is apparently not working right now.
So, give me a sec.
Let me grab my controller.
Where'd my roller go?
Where is it?
Where'd it go?
Huh?
Where'd roller go?
Where's my controller?
Where'd I put it?
I'm so confused.
Oh, there it is.
It's behind all the other stuff.
Alright, I found it.
Every day, we learn something new.
And I'll slowly wake up.
There we go.
Alright.
Okay, let me turn down the sound effects, too.
I noticed that the sound effects are very loud sometimes.
So, I'm turning that down a little.
Actually, I'm turning that down a little.
I've noticed that after the stream.
Alright, let me make sure.
Let me get the game up.
Croquis is ready to clock in to a 9-to-5.
Where is Death's Door?
There we go.
I can't wait to finish.
This is a really fun game, though.
I actually really... I forgot all the controls.
As an IQ of a small child, I've already forgotten all the controls.
Oh, 32%?
Nice.
That's what I like to see.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay, we're changing this weapon.
This weapon fucking sucked.
The moment I put that weapon on, I fucking died.
Also, I'm lost.
Was it this way?
Oh, I remember.
I'm not lost.
Okay, how do I... How do I... How?
Roll... Okay.
How do I do... Oh, there's the... Okay, there we go.
I figured it out.
No more how.
Now it's do.
Handiclocks, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Please tell your anime girl handler to read the... I threw away the manual.
There's no more manual.
There may or may not be any more manual.
Croaky was like... Sorry, Doki was like, who needs that?
Doki no need that.
Doki a free bird.
Okay, I think it's this way.
Right?
I don't remember.
Yeah, it's this way.
I'm going backwards.
And then we go down here.
Wait, what?
Where'd the hole at?
Oh, I fell down the hole.
Okay.
It's not this way, guys.
I'm getting a little lost.
Okay, it's this way.
I remember now.
I remember.
It's this way.
And then... Guys, I don't remember.
Someone send help.
Oh, there you go.
I remember.
I don't know how I got here, but I did it.
I don't know how I got here, but we don't worry about that.
Okay, there we go.
There we go.
Never talk about the destination.
Just always talk about the destination, not how we got there.
Okay, nice.
I don't know if I can hit the arrow.
I cannot hit the arrow, guys.
I don't know.
I reflected everything else.
Why couldn't I reflect that?
Oh my god, no.
That's fucked up.
They can throw bombs now?
Oh, nice.
Oh, fuck!
It's okay.
It's not okay.
Guys, it's not okay anymore.
How arrow?
Guys, how arrow?
Guys, arrow how?
Okay, no more fancy.
Oh, fuck, no!
Zyko, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god.
I hope your leg's okay.
I broke my right leg at the age of 25.
It took six months.
Where do I go?
It was this way, right?
I couldn't run at top speed anymore.
Do take care of yourself as you get older.
Some things are hard to fix.
Don't worry.
Maybe the minerals will get out of my system, guys.
I actually never broken a bone before.
It's crazy.
I've done a lot of fucked up shit to my body, but I've never broken a bone, which is pretty insane.
That I have not... I've not done that yet.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Never broken a bone before.
No.
I've like twisted my ankles so many times though, but I've never broken...
Oh, shit, there's a seed.
Alright, time to... time to kidnap.
Oh, I can't.
You guys are so lucky I can't kidnap.
Oh, wait, I can.
No, wait, I can't.
God damn it.
I can't kidnap you guys.
Sorry.
I know you really want me... I know you really want dad to take custody right now, but I can't.
Okay, I figured it out.
Okay.
Oh my god.
His hammer is so fast.
Like, I... I feel like I only have like one sec... like one second.
Okay, now I know the range.
Okay, nice.
I know the range now.
Pew!
Okay.
Okay, shoot the arrow.
Shoot the arrow.
Nice.
Okay, I know the range.
Oh, what?
That hit... what hit me?
What even hit me?
Oh my god, these guys.
These fuckers.
I don't know how to use arrow.
I forgot.
That was something I was trying to... that was something I was trying to do earlier, but then I forgot about it.
Oh wait, I have Kamiha!
Oh shit, okay.
Okay, this is bad.
I was just trying to remember moves, guys.
Also, V, thank you for the very first super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Also, got my Doki Gamer Subs today.
Croaky Cup when?
Thank you.
Super chat, thank you, thank you.
Your very first one.
Maybe in the future, I don't know.
I don't know.
That would be cool.
Would people want to buy a Croaky Cup?
Gamer Subs Cup?
Because Gamer Subs' whole branding is like half-naked anime woman.
So like, would people buy a Cro?
Like, my cup is one of the rare cups that's not half-naked suggestive anime woman.
It's like one of the few cups that they've done that isn't that.
So I'm just like, would people be interested?
I fucking hate you!
I hope your family dies!
Croaky will make sure.
Oh my god.
Croaky will make sure you have no more family.
I will find your wife and child and end the bloodline.
You think Croaky won't?
Croaky has nothing to lose.
Caw, caw.
Get over here.
I beat you up.
Oh wait, what the fuck?
Okay, usually these guys take really fast.
Okay, these guys, fuck these guys.
Actually, fuck these guys.
I hate these guys so much.
They're so hard.
They're actually so- ah!
Okay, we got one of them out of here.
Guys, I'm like, waking up right now.
I f-
I forgot there's no invisible- birds can't swim.
This bird can't swim.
I forgot there's no invisible walls.
When you go down, you die.
Oh, I forgot.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I forgot!
Just like my hair, as you get older, you lose the very things you hold dear.
It tears your hair and drags on for us.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
After that, I need to hydrate.
I need to hydrate.
Guys, I'm waking up.
Okay, I'm locked in now.
I'm actually locked in for real now, guys.
I swear to God.
I swear to God, I'm locked in for real.
Okay, I'm locked in now, I swear.
Ignore that first shot.
I swear to God, I'm locked in for real now.
Okay, now I am.
Guys, now I'm locked in.
Okay, okay, everything is okay.
I would never lie.
Okay.
Get the- okay, now I'm locked in for real.
Oh my- WHAT?!
That should be illegal!
Oh my God.
That should actually be illegal.
Okay.
Alright.
This is fine.
They're in a line.
Oh my God, they're in a line just for- just for me.
Oh my God, I hate these guys so much.
Okay, we got another one.
Get in a single file, please.
Alright, slow- guys, I've learned.
See, slow and steady.
Slow and steady, guys.
Get in the line!
Line!
There we go.
Guys, see?
Okay, I just need to not fall in the water.
Imagine if I fell in the water right after.
Okay, it sucks.
Stuck to rot for eternity in a dungeon.
There's nothing down here but grime, filth, and little frogs.
Sounded like- the way he said that sounded like a slur.
Damn crows.
Damn.
Are crows the most racist out of the bird family?
No, those are- those are ravens.
Uh, Lord Kurosis, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
This is the most rhetorical thing I've ever heard you say.
I'll take 20, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, this way.
Guys, I'm- I gotta plant my seed.
Alright, children, heal- heal daddy.
Yay!
What?
How do I get over here?
Okay, I need to get over there.
Alright.
Let's get him out of the way.
Kill the plants too.
Okay, nice.
And then we light that up.
And then we light this up.
Now what to?
Oh.
And then, come over here.
Get- ow!
I- I forgot that happens.
I'm just being silly.
Oh wait, it's timed.
Oh fuck, it's timed?
Wait, I need to hit something then.
What can I hit?
I didn't know it's timed.
I need to be able to hit something.
I only have two.
Oh my god.
Also, Mack, thank you for the- thank you for the five gifted ships.
Thank you, thank you.
What do I hit?
Oh, the mushrooms.
Okay, mushrooms can be- can be regrown.
Okay.
There we go.
I did it.
I'm so smart.
Yippee.
I'm a smart bird.
Oh, I fucking hate these.
I forgot about these guys.
Yeah, cry.
Cry to your dad.
Oh, you don't have a dad.
I forgot.
That's right.
Don't have any parental figures.
That's why you're out here terrorizing us.
Alright, sorry.
Goki has a lot of hate today.
I've been going through a lot right now.
Okay, how do I- wait, no, I'm back here.
Wait, what?
I'm back here.
I have a lot of minerals inside me.
There's an overabundance of minerals inside this body right now.
Okay, wait, did it destroy the rock?
No, it didn't.
How do I get- I feel like I need to use this to destroy something down here.
Okay, I don't know.
I'm so confused.
Okay,
where do I- where's the last one?
I don't know where the last one is.
Oh, fuck!
What the-?
Oh, wait, it reset itself because I fucked up.
I almost forgot about that.
Where do I go?
What?
Oh, no.
No,
I'm not fast enough!
Unless... No, I'm not.
I'm not fast enough.
No.
Oh, I'm so lost.
I'm so lost.
Where do I go?
Where are the five people that play this game?
Children, get over here.
Feed the croaky.
Get out of here.
Croaky has been fed.
I don't need you children anymore.
I'm so lost.
I'm back here.
Where?
Okay, maybe here?
Maybe a secret door?
Could be a secret door here, right?
Secret door?
Oh.
No, no secret door.
No secret door.
Oh.
No, this is where I got the other crow.
Guys, where are the three people that play this game?
Where's the last door?
Guys, I feel like I've been everywhere.
I skipped it?
How?
How do I just skip something?
Wait, someone is... Oh my god, the one person.
The three people that play this game.
Get over here.
Where go?
Go where?
Go down?
Here?
I'm down.
Now where?
Bomb flower on the door?
Still down?
Okay, keep going down.
Okay.
Let me get rid of... Oh, fuck!
Okay, I don't care.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, maybe I do have to care.
Oh my god!
Okay, that's a lot of them.
Okay, I care now.
To my right.
My right?
To my right?
Okay, I can get rid of these guys fast.
Here?
Is it here?
Oh!
The frog king's domain!
I'm coming to your house!
Was I here before?
I don't remember.
Yeah, no, I wasn't.
How do I get the... Oh!
Not there, okay.
Okay, not here.
I was gonna be like, knock knock!
I'm here for your house!
Oh, wait, have I not done that door yet?
I never just went down?
Oh shit, I never went down!
How did I never... Oh, fuck!
How did I never went down?
That's crazy, I never went down.
That's actually crazy.
Croaky doesn't know how to go down, she always goes up.
Okay, nice.
Not nice.
Oh, definitely not nice anymore.
Okay, what the fuck?
Why are you blocking my way?
Oh!
Oh my god, I actually dodged that.
I don't know how, but I did it.
Okay.
I can only hit like one time.
His hammer speed is so fucking fast, it's actually crazy.
Okay, nice.
Okay, it's just the bugs.
Nothing to worry about.
Okay, let me get rid of the fire plant first.
I don't trust him.
Nice.
Okay, nice.
What the fuck, you can dodge?
That's illegal!
Alright, these guys were easy.
Can't believe it.
Plant the seed.
Okay, I need to actually consume the seed.
Hello!
I'm a hero to here to free you!
Only croaky dodge.
Exactly.
Goodbye!
Your people need you!
As in, me.
I use your soul for my amusement.
Goodbye, crow!
Goodbye!
Alright, we go this way.
What's up here?
What is up here?
Hello?
Oh, hey, nice.
Yoink, taking the kids.
My children now.
Where am I?
Where the fuck am I?
Where did I- what?
Oh, it's the other entrance!
But why go there?
I guess it's like a shortcut.
Okay, yeah.
Figure out a shortcut.
Okay, now we have to go all the way back.
I don't need to pay child support.
You have no mom.
Your mom is literally a pot.
How do I get to this guy trapped in there?
I guess I need to get a bomb.
Maybe the ability I unlocked is a bomb or something.
Okay, we go this way.
Hello, knock knock.
I'm here.
Be wary, living reaper.
I don't need to be worried.
I have minerals in my body now.
I can only go up.
Okay, I don't have bomb.
Goodbye, pots.
Well, I'm ready.
Give me your special skill.
I'm ready to go in.
Don't worry, it's consensual kidnapping.
I already knew he was gonna do that.
Awaris.
What are these?
Oh wait, these guys are easy.
I almost forgot what they- Let me get rid of the plants.
Get rid of range first.
Oh my god, whenever he throws a bomb it like fucks me up because I forget he does that.
I forget his range.
Okay, nice.
I can farm more Kamehamehas with these.
Okay, don't worry.
I know how to kill these guys.
They're tiny.
Oh my god, he's not tiny anymore.
Why is he so big?
Oh my god, wait.
He's not tiny.
I got baited.
No, not you.
Not you.
Anything but you.
No, not him.
Oh fuck.
Not you.
Oh thank god.
Okay, okay.
I'm just happy not him.
I cannot deal with him.
Okay, one last one.
Jesus Christ, get over here.
You're not special.
Okay, wait, he's green.
Oh, he's green!
Gotta get rid of green first.
I was like, wait, he's green.
Wait, I've never seen him green before.
I was like, wait a minute.
What does green mean?
Oh my god, green was extra scary.
Okay, nice.
Okay, that was a lot easier.
I'm surprised they didn't spam the big guy.
If they spammed the big guy, I would've been like, okay, that would've been a problem.
Green.
No, not the green!
Color of the frogs.
Hello, bird Jesus.
A gift to a fellow crow to aid you on your quest.
Thank you, bird Jesus.
On the seventh day, he rose from the chest.
Bombs- I knew it!
I knew it was like...
Okay, I knew it.
I knew it was like a special spell for it.
There were so many areas where I needed a bomb.
How do I do it?
Put your hands up!
I'm making a spirit bomb!
Oh my god.
Wait, I hurt myself.
Wait, what do you mean?
Oh shit!
Oh, I chucked bombs!
Oh my god.
Okay, now I know, guys.
Oh my god, that's fucking cool.
No, I like- no, I didn't- I like threw it at myself.
I don't know if you guys know this, but when you're next to a grenade, you can hurt yourself, guys.
I know it's a crazy concept.
How much is it?
Oh, it takes like two as well.
Oh my god, it takes so much.
Shocker, I know, guys.
This is why you don't throw grenades next to you.
Koki learned today.
Koki learned the concept of ricochet damage.
Okay, open.
No way, ain't no way.
I don't know, I thought I was invincible!
Heh.
Heh heh.
Okay.
Wait, did he touch my door?
Did he fucking touch my door?
Where am I?
Oh, that's a lot of doors I haven't yet opened.
Oh no, it's right here.
Wait, then what's over there?
Wait a minute, then what's down here?
Is there anything down here?
Oh, there is.
Wait, what?
Where does this go?
Oh, it's just secret.
Okay, I have fire.
Okay, that should open it.
Secret!
Pick up the money.
I'll pick up a door.
Sending a query to head office, but they insisted that this was normal procedure and the case was closed.
Still no word from my colleague.
He mentioned he was being assigned to assist a powerful witch until some research... it was some research last time we had lunch.
He said he was a bit worried before he started, but it turned out she was quite a nice old lady.
I wonder if she had anything to do with the closure.
Okay.
I don't think he'll like to know that I used his soul as a door.
I hope he's alright.
Well, he's part of a door now.
Is that what all reapers always wanted to be?
Part of a door?
He lives by the door, he dies by the door.
What a great life.
It's like when you die and then your remains are used for corpo.
Thing is, you never leave.
You can never escape.
Why is a child here?
So joyful, so carefree, so annoying.
I didn't say it, Dragoon.
I didn't say it.
Dragoon, you're not annoying, okay?
You are a great health resource.
Let me tell you that.
These funny little forest spirits have appeared out of nowhere.
It caused quite a stir around the office.
God, it's so hot.
Finally, it's getting hotter, though.
It's been, like, so cold for, like, a couple of months now.
I had to file a lot of paperwork due to the infestation.
It's great.
I think this one likes me.
Oh, wait.
No, no!
You're not just HP, guys.
I would never.
I planted you for a reason.
Okay, I should have enough to upgrade.
Oh, no, I don't.
We're going full strength.
We're maxing out strength and then we'll care about the other stuff later.
Oh, fuck, I almost fell down.
Where did I go?
I forgot which one was the frogs.
It's been too long.
Oh, wait, maybe it's right side?
I hate it when they, like, bring me to a new area and I'm like, oh, I don't remember which door is for which!
Okay, maybe it's, like, far left.
Lost Cemetery.
Could be far left, right?
Ceramic Manor.
I don't remember.
No, it's not.
Which door is which one?
It's down?
Oh, my God, I'm so lost.
Croaky Lost.
Okay, it's downstairs.
Is it this one?
Oh, it's here.
Okay, it's here.
I figured it out, guys.
Mushroom Dungeon.
Is it Mushroom?
Or is it over?
Oh, we'll find out.
We'll fucking find out.
Trial and error.
Where is this?
Okay, it's not here.
Okay, it's Mushroom.
I opened it and I was like, why am I outside?
Okay, there we go.
I can free him now.
And you shall be freed.
Oh, I didn't... Okay, whoops.
You shall be freed.
I did it.
Little bird save Grunt.
Grunt be forever, thank little bird.
Yay!
Is that it?
You're not gonna give me anything?
I didn't do this for free, big guy.
I would like some rewards, thank you very much.
I know, like, there's more things for me to explode somewhere.
There's, like, other areas to, like, blow up.
But where?
Oh, here.
Ow.
Whoops.
That's alright, that's what the children here are for.
Alright, where is this?
Oh, okay.
Oh, wait, there's another area!
Where does this go?
Where am I?
Where the fuck am I?
Okay, I need to recharge this then.
Okay.
There we go.
Where the fuck am I?
Okay, this way?
Oh!
Praise be!
Please grant me HP!
Bird God!
I request HP!
I have two?
Wait, that's not an HP!
Wait!
I need to find two more, goddammit.
Bird God is so stingy.
Alright, we found this area.
I don't remember all the areas that haveoh, thank god.
I knew planting you was the right idea.
Oh, wait, rightokay, so...
Obviously, it should be around here.
Where there's, like, a secret area.
Yeah, I knew it.
Yay!
Upgrade!
Is there anything here?
No, this is different.
Oh, down here!
Yeah.
Yeah, I remember.
And then, up here.
And then, kaboom.
Yay!
I got a branch!
I wonder what creature this used to be attached to.
Oh, wait, it does nothing.
Okay, it was just collectible.
Nevermind, I wasted my time.
Nevermind.
I got a cool stick!
I wasted my time and got a cool-ass stick.
Where do I go?
It's here, right?
Oh, shit.
Alright, and then we go this way.
I should have enough now.
I'm gonna fucking- I'm coming over.
I didn't pay rent, but I'm gonna come over anyway!
Boom!
That's five booms!
The crooked crow doesn't give up easily, huh?
You know out there, I'm the tiny frog in a big pond.
But here, I'm the top of the food chain.
And my favorite meal is all those delicious stray souls.
You got your work cut out for you, Reaper.
My subjects will see to that.
Then it's crow pie for supper.
And trifle for dessert.
Our chef makes the fantastic trifle.
That's five booms!
Oh, I missed.
Sorry.
I don't wanna waste my resources, so I'm just gonna slap you.
Oh, I can't even slap you.
Oh, there you go.
Just don't wanna waste it!
Flooded fortress.
Okay, now I have to charge up my- I need to charge this up.
Do the mushrooms grow back?
Oh, they don't.
Okay, we need to- Oh, they do!
Okay, nice.
Child, come with me.
Hello?
Froggy frog?
Are you here?
Slap!
Whoa!
What happens if I- Oh, it doesn't do anything.
Oh, that's cool.
I need to remember not to, like, accidentally walk off.
Because they don't have invisible walls.
Because they'd punish you if you, like- They actually punish you for not going- For not having hand-eye coordination.
Imagine having really bad hand-eye coordination trying to fucking walk in a straight line.
Okay, that should open something.
No, I need to actually- What?
Bomb?
No?
Not bomb?
Maybe arrow?
Oh, okay.
Okay, it just doesn't like fire.
Understandable, understandable.
Just doesn't like fire.
Alright, let's see.
Where else do I go?
How do I get up here?
Is there- Okay, there's a guy over there.
Hello?
For the frog fortress, there's surprisingly a very lack of frogs.
There's a huge lack of frogs.
I don't know if I'm going the right way.
There's so many, like, passages.
Okay,
there's a guy that's just staring.
He's like, what a lovely day to just look out there.
Goodbye.
Oh, I knew there was a child here.
Oh, secret!
What a worthless secret.
I can't even teleport.
Can't believe it.
Amy- oh my god.
That means I have to backtrack here whenever I can teleport.
AHHHHHH That's fine.
That's fine.
I don't have it.
Whenever I can do whatever that shit is.
I can't jump, guys.
I don't have the ability to jump.
What did I miss at?
What?
I guess that was just a secret.
Look, this bird was not meant to go up.
Can you read?
Wait, can I actually ground pound?
Oh!
Oh my god, I figured it out all by myself.
Secret tunnel!
Yay!
Holy shit, lots of secret.
I could go down here, but then I could get this.
I could've gone there though.
What is over there?
Wait, what is over there?
Oh my god, they go all the way back.
Oh no, oh that guy's drowning.
I'm so smart.
Okay, I'm gonna do that again.
I wanna know what all the way there is.
Okay, I'm so smart.
Phew, figured that out all by myself.
Roll, roll, roll.
Hello, what do I have over here?
Hello everybody.
Hey guys.
How do I get over there?
Oh, okay.
Nice.
Anything over here?
Oh my god, it's such a maze.
Oh my god.
Oh, it's back here, okay.
Oh fuck, I'm drowning.
Okay, I'm okay.
JK, I'm okay now.
What happened?
I'll never know.
I'm okay though.
I was never drowning by the way.
I don't like this area.
This area is way too confus- There's so many passages that I'm actually so confused right now.
A bird was never meant to think this far.
Hello children.
Come to daddy crow.
Oh, I have to go this way?
Where are all the frogs?
Wait, I swear I've only found one fucking frog and he's supposed to be the king of frogs.
If he's the king of frogs, why is there one frog?
Who are you a king of?
Oh, I got it.
Wait, but I wanna get rid of these boxes.
I knew there was a child here.
That's right.
Oh my god, it's guarded by one guy.
Like, what is that one guy gonna do?
He takes 20 seconds to load in an arrow.
Okay, this way?
I'll grab the bomb.
The bomb is the strongest, technically.
Okay, is there an arrow here?
No?
Alright, we go this way.
Then unlock this door.
And then... oh my god, what you gonna do?
Nothing.
Oh fuck!
Okay, you did something.
Got a little cocky there.
Where are the children?
How would I plant my seed?
Where are they?
Where are the pots?
Hey there.
An intruder!
And- Wow, they're called the red shirts?
Wow.
Okay.
And they're intruding!
You'll regret this flierent trespass.
You're done for now, little bird.
You're gonna get crushed!
Oh fuck, hey.
You're certainly persistent, crooked crow.
Do you like my armor?
It was a size too small, but I think I make it work.
Can you believe I found it just lying around on a nearby corpse?
Here's just another bleeding heart standing in the way of progress.
This is the natural order!
The strong survive!
Hop on, small fry!
Oh yeah?
You heard him!
Hop on!
I sure hope I don't end up between those chubby green cheeks.
You know, some people will pay for that.
You know what I just found out?
Okay, so like...
This popped up in my- okay, I don't know why.
Okay, this reminded me of this.
But like, last night I was reading Twitter.
And I get all my news on Twitter, if you guys didn't know that.
I feel like you guys know with my brain rot.
And like, they're saying like, the reason why the Matrix film deteriorated in the trilogy...
Is because the Wachowski sisters now, they were the Wachowski brothers.
And like, after the first film, they got into a sex dungeon.
And like, got like, injected with ketamine and shit.
And it like, fucked up their minds.
They got into like, this BDSM sex dungeon thing.
And wait, you guys didn't know that?
Yeah, and then I read the article and it was like, true.
And I was like, no, that can't- there's no way.
Wait, you guys didn't know- no, it's actually true!
It's actually- it's actually true!
They got into like, some freaky sex dungeon BDSM shit after the first film.
And then like, the reason why the films deteriorated is because like, they were- they got injected with ketamine.
And like, it fried their brains after the first film.
Yeah, so that's why the later movies got really weird.
Yeah, I said it's not- it's not a fanfic, it's actually true!
It's a true story, I was- I even- I even- I'm linking it, I'm linking it, I'm linking the thing.
I was like, what the fuck?
Mickey, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
You should see Jupiter ascending, it's so ass.
Okay, look- alright.
Look at- here, click this, and then like, look at the replies.
I was like, there's no- no fucking way.
Like, look- look at the replies, it's actually crazy.
I was like, holy fuck, what?
Anyway, um, are you sure this isn't the Minerals talking?
Robin, thank you for the super chat, thank you.
No, it's not!
It's not the Robin, it's not the Minerals in my system!
It's not the Minerals, I swear.
You can even see in the Wikipedia, it's actually in the Wikipedia!
I even looked up their Wikipedia, and what it said like that, they got into some freaky sex dungeon shit.
Because like, um, what's her name?
Laura, or whatever, the first Wachowski sister?
It was like, yeah, like, they started, they started, after like, um, the wife divorced her because like, she cheated on her with the BDSM mistress.
That they met at the sex dungeon.
Oh my god!
And then the BDSM mistress was like, one of the best mistresses out there.
I was like, holy shit!
I did not know this about the Matrix!
Fun fact!
Fun fact about the Matrix series.
Isn't that such a fun fact, guys?
What a fun fact.
I sure...
Okay, the more you learn with Croaky, and you believe this video got on Twitter, why?
Also, how is this related?
Because he was like, I sure hope I don't get squished between those cheeks, and I just thought about...
Thank you for the super chat, D-Dragon, thank you, thank you.
My fun is like my optimism.
God.
Alright, nice.
Wait, it's actually, yes it is!
Why would I lie?!
Why would Croaky lie?
Alright, let's go all in on the strength.
He said the strongest will survive.
I shall be the strongest.
Croaky never lies.
I didn't need to know this.
But it was such a fun fact!
Did you guys have fun?
Alright.
It was a fact.
It was a cool fact.
Fun is the strongest.
It was a cool... Okay, how about a cool fact?
A cool fact is like fun.
Alright, hello.
Oh fuck, okay.
Oh fuck, okay, I didn't realize he was gonna slam.
I like the Matrix episodes.
Okay, I'm just gonna arrow these guys for now.
Because they're bothering me.
Wait, what?
How can I... Oh, wait, I thought like... I was like, wait, can I hit that?
It's a boomerang.
So I should be able to hit that, right?
Theoretically.
That was crazy.
I did not... That still blows my mind.
That like, they were part of a sex dungeon.
Alright, nice.
I'm not gonna ignore that.
I'm still trying to process it.
That like, blew my mind.
The director is a Matrix.
Alright, let's get this guy out of here.
Get out of here.
All that leather?
I didn't think about the leather that way.
Everything I learned about BDSM has been against my will.
Whoops.
Guys, did you not have fun?
Okay.
Let's see.
Alright.
Ow!
Fuck!
I thought, okay.
I know why I didn't learn my lesson.
I know why I thought it would be different this time.
Okay, let's get these guys out of here.
You're annoying.
Okay, we go down?
We go down this way.
Where are the frogs at?
I was promised frogs!
Why is it one guy?
Where the fu- Oh shit!
Oh no.
Oh no, this is bad.
Where are the frogs?
Ow!
Sorry, I demanded too many frogs.
Moral of the story, don't do drugs, kids.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
No name.
Simpa, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Why would I lie?
This is coming from the person who lapsed in Dynasty War.
I didn't relapse!
I'm all better now.
Boom.
Oh wow.
He fell into the water.
I didn't relapse.
I'm reformed.
That's different.
Guys, I swear to god, I'm reformed.
Okay.
Nice, he's dead.
Can you remember how to get there?
Oh, it's this way.
Okay.
It's been a while.
I know I- Doki, you died like five sec- Guys, it's been a while.
Okay, and then we go- I'm just gonna skip through all of these.
Unless they like start chasing me.
Yeah, they're not chasing me, right?
Is he gonna jump down?
There's no way he's gonna jump down, right?
He can.
He physically can't go down.
Yeah, he can.
Okay.
That's good.
I wasn't sure, so I have to like- I just wanna be sure I'm not gonna see like big boy over there jumping down on me.
Okay, nevermind, he jumped down.
Oh, he still can!
He still can!
Wait, it's still possible.
He can't jump.
Ah!
Oh my god, I'm like getting- I'm actually- Oh, I need to get these guys out of here.
Come on, blow your- Blow your hole.
There you go.
I don't think he can.
Oh, no, he can.
Wait, that's illegal!
That's illegal!
That's so illegal!
What you doing here?
Go back on high ground!
Wait, wait, wait.
El Mexican, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I have to go to my appointment with my therapist, Doki.
I guess I have a topic to share now!
See you later!
Oh, you wanna share your fun fact with your therapist?
What a great fun fact.
I'm glad- I'm glad you're sharing other facts too with her.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Serfin, thank you for the super chat.
Oh, Brainwrap Bird of the Interwebs, what is your-
That's - That's it.
That's the fun fact of the day.
Unless...
That's today's fun fact.
Don't worry.
Croquis will come back with more fun.
At another time.
Alright.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Import- Exactly.
They're very important!
They're educational!
Now you know!
If you guys ever wondered why the trilogy became like that, now you know.
That's crazy.
Apparently it's like supposedly common knowledge, but apparently not.
People replies are like, wait, people did not know that?
It's common knowledge.
Apparently not!
Apparently it was absolutely not common knowledge.
Okay, let's get him out of the way.
Define common.
Common!
That's- That's what it's like to get older, guys.
Welcome to adulthood.
Alright.
Let's see.
Okay, we gotta kill these guys.
I think it- Yeah, I was gonna- Oh, that looked- That's cool.
Oh, shit!
Seeds!
Come on, children!
Give me my HP, child!
Yay!
Health!
Yippee!
Hey, you know the best part?
You can spread the knowledge to other people.
Now other people shall know about the beautiful knowledge that you gained.
Oh my god, really?!
What?!
Oh!
This is not fair.
That was not fair.
Oh my god, he took the bullet!
Okay, well now I know it does that.
Okay.
I wanna like- Okay, now I know it does that much damage.
I don't know how much damage that does.
We go this way.
And then we hit this thing.
And then we go this way.
Oh!
We hit that.
Oh, you think- Oh, shit.
Nevermind.
I was gonna say...
Okay, get this guy out of the way.
I need to kill this guy, though.
Come on, you're almost dead!
Nice.
We get his.
Get this.
I think his therapist will need- Wait, can I chuck- Oh, fuck.
Okay.
Get over here!
Okay, I was gonna say, he better fucking die after that.
Oh, which way- Oh, seeds!
Come here, children.
Croaky needs HP.
It's Croaky's custody hours.
Oh, shit!
Can you throw- Can you throw that boomerang first before I come down?
Come on, get over here.
As long as he doesn't throw the boomerang, he's pretty much useless.
Alright, nice.
Oh, there is invincibility frames!
I learned that now.
I know, like, it's sort of self-explanatory that there should be.
Just cause, like, it's a souls-like.
But, like, it felt like it did not feel like it sometimes.
It really did not feel like I was invincible.
Okay.
Alright, up I go.
I'm gonna plant another one.
I have a lot of seeds.
Go down here.
Jesus Christ, there's so many!
Oh!
Oh my god!
What a dodge!
Oh, it doesn't matter!
That's infecting matter!
Okay.
Oh, it's so hard to charge the Kamehameha.
Because they're all here.
Okay, I'm gonna get rid of the little guys first.
Since they...
They take...
Longer to charge up.
Oh, fuck!
Are you serious?!
Oh!
I sure love my family-friendly Oshie!
Marco, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Like, it doesn't stagger him at all!
Oh, this is bad.
It's glowing.
I don't think it's glowing.
I don't feel good when it starts glowing.
I don't feel so good when it starts glowing.
Oh!
Oh my god, are you serious?!
How many arrows are there?!
No!
I just rolled into it!
I have to do it all over again!
Fuck these guys.
Okay.
Okay, at least I have a shortcut.
I think.
I don't remember where this goes!
Where did I go?!
Where's the shortcut?
Oh, it's this way.
Okay, I'm just gonna run past all these guys.
There's no way it's gonna punish me for that.
Okay.
Okay, now...
Now I surely won't get punished, right?
Oh, I can!
Oh my god, children, I need you to heal me right now.
Okay.
This is fine.
This is absolutely fine.
Okay, and now...
They can't climb ladders, I remembered!
Oh my god, okay, we're fine.
We're actually fine.
They can't climb ladders.
Oh, that's so helpful.
And then we go this way.
Okay.
Alright, we go this way.
Was it this way?
Yeah, it was.
Okay, it was.
Okay, everything's fine right now.
See, look at that!
Not punished!
Not punished for my crimes!
Okay, nice.
We got rid of this guy.
Never punished, let's go!
That's right, I'm better at this than you.
Alright.
Uh...
Thank you for your super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
I'm afraid... Wait, I'm back here.
Wait.
Wait a minute.
I planted seed here.
Um...
I'm confused.
Wait a minute.
This doesn't make sense.
Wait, where do I go?
Wait, what?
Oh, wait, no, it's here!
Cause he's wearing gold!
Why he's gold?
Ow!
Okay.
Yeah, I was like, I was like, I never planted that.
I don't remember planting.
That's a new path, yeah.
Okay, thank God that the children are still here.
I got a little confused.
I didn't see the arrow, guys.
I got a little silly.
Oh my God, he's gold.
Oh my God!
Oh, it's these guys!
Are you serious?
Get out of... Oh!
Guys, my pathway's gone.
What the...
Wait, it does that?
How am I...
Is it just gone forever?
Is it just...
Wait.
It's just...
Is it just gone forever?
Where did it go?
Maybe... Oh, I can recover it!
Oh, thank God!
I was like...
What?
Where's my pathway?
Where did it go?
I wonder if there's anything over there.
No, there isn't.
Oh my God, what do I do here?
I'm like, not okay right now.
There we go.
Why did I not insta-kill you, buddy?
That's literally a fucking bomb to the face.
I'm actually too scared to...
I'm too scared to, like, be aggro right now.
I'm like one hit.
I'm actually... I don't want to do this.
I don't want to run past these guys again.
I need my shortcuts.
I need to activate as many shortcuts as possible right now.
Oh, thank God!
I think I activated... That was a shortcut, right?
That had to be a shortcut to activate.
No, it's... Yeah.
No, it is.
Yeah, because there's a child there.
There's a child that I've... Oh, there's another child.
Oh, please.
Please.
Please give me... No!
No!
A child!
Alright.
Okay, we're doing it again.
It's okay, I can run past everything.
I don't remember where that activated shortcut was, though.
Oh my God, where am I?
Was it here?
Yes!
Child!
Yes, it is.
Okay.
Get out!
Daddy's working.
Okay, we're here.
We figured it out, guys.
We don't have to do too... Oh, thank God.
We don't have to do a lot of backtracking.
Thank fucking God.
Daddy's working right now, children!
Oh my God, did the children run off the cliff?
Oh my... I'm not a terrible father.
Wait!
They're gone!
Oh shit!
I didn't mean it, children!
Wait!
They just ran off the cliff!
Guys!
I didn't mean for you to run off!
Okay, you killed them.
No!
When I said get away, I didn't mean go out to the cliff!
No, it's not me!
Is it?
Oh my God, there's so many.
Okay.
Spy.
What?
Okay, guys, they're already dead.
There's no need to call the CPS.
Like, who are they protecting when they're dead?
If you think about it, CPS is useless when the children are already gone.
Yeah, call the police instead, you're right.
You're right.
Alright, nice, we did it.
Okay, we should need to do...
Arrow.
Alright.
Oh, it's calm now.
It's so calm.
After the fucking mess that we just did there.
Bird, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I know you finally have the croquis plush.
Thank you, Doki, my bird.
Yes!
Guys, you guys didn't know.
We have two weeks left, two weeks of the YouTube plushie, which includes croquis.
That's me, I'm croquis.
Yeah, bye now.
More purchases equals more opportunities in the future.
Okay, now we beat up the frog.
That's me.
The link is pinned in the chat.
So, upgrades?
Not yet, guys.
I only upgrade strength.
We're on the bunga build.
Croquet crow!
Oh, do you think he knows?
No, there's no way he didn't see me kill those kids.
Yeah, he doesn't know, guys.
It's for my other crimes.
Fail to teach you a lesson, so I have to do it myself.
After I'm done with you, I'll use your feathers to buff my armor and make it all shiny.
I'll be the most handsome creature under the shadow of the door.
Alright, squishy time!
King of the swamp.
Oh my god, he's so big.
I am like crouch-sized.
Lord of his domain.
Ruler of all he survives.
Champion of the people.
Keeper of the five oaths.
First of his name.
Okay, I guess I'll never know.
Wait, what?
I guess I drown?
What the fuck?!
Okay.
Wait, what?
Okay, that does do damage.
Okay, now I know.
I had no idea what does damage for him for a sec.
Okay, that's not that bad.
I'll just do this.
Nice.
Okay, this moveset is not that scary.
I'll just throw bombs at him.
Nice!
Get outta here!
Yeah, that's right!
Oh!
Okay.
How much more does he- ow, fuck!
Okay, he bounces more now.
Okay, now I know.
Now I know, his range is further.
Okay, he has further range.
Oh, oh, oh!
Oh my god, the range is so far.
Nice, I got the other one.
Alright, I don't think I'm gonna win this round because like, I sort of fucked up in the beginning.
Oh, he's so fast.
Spirit Bomb!
But he's so fast now though.
Okay.
Alright, nice.
Oh, he's coming over.
Oh!
Spirit Bomb!
I'm trying to make sure he doesn't break up too many.
So I still have like, a little bit room to breathe.
There we go.
We got another one.
This sage is like- oh, shit!
What the fuck?!
Okay, okay, now he's- Now he's big boy.
Oh!
Woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah.
Woah!
Oh my god!
He's so big!
What the-?
Oh, shit!
Oh, this is actually concerning now.
Oh, this is- this is so concerning.
Oh, and I- What the-?
Oh, that was an accident!
Oh!
I'm actually concerned.
Oh, please don't.
This is my only tile.
Oh my god!
Oh my god.
Okay, now I know.
Now I know, guys.
Now I know.
I figured it out.
Okay, I figured it out.
Okay, so I cannot waste- Okay, I need not waste- I need not waste my- My bombs on- when he's big boy.
Big boy is a little scary.
Now I know.
Because, like, I need to recover my tiles.
And I did not have that.
I did not- I had no more- I had no more energy for the tiles.
Oh.
Bomb!
These I can waste bomb on.
But don't waste bomb on the others, Doki.
Kroki.
Sorry.
Lapse of judgment.
Yes, he does more.
Okay.
Alright.
What am I doing?
Oh, I can't.
That was a waste.
Wait, did I hit him?
What the fuck?
Did I hit him there?
Oh, nice.
I did it.
Ooh.
Oh no, now he's big boy.
Hello.
Oh my god, okay.
Okay, I'm not gonna waste it yet.
Actually, no, I can.
I'm not gonna waste it yet.
Alright.
Big suck.
Okay.
Nice.
Okay, that's good.
I'm not gonna waste it.
Don't waste the arrows.
Woo!
Ah, what?!
Okay!
That was actually bullshit!
Oh my god!
Okay!
That's fucked up!
That lost two HP for no reason there.
That was actually fucked up.
Oh my god!
That shouldn't be a thing!
That's actually so cheap!
Holy fuck!
Oh my god!
Let's stay back here.
This feels like the safest.
I can't believe...
Oh my god, that actually...
That's actually so fucked up.
How was I doing?!
He literally spawned me into the water!
Like, why did it spawn me in the water?!
Yeah, that's right.
Be the fat frog you are.
Oh my god!
Okay, that was a little worrisome.
Okay, nice.
Oh!
Is he gonna do any new moves or is it just that?
I'm not risking it.
I am absolutely not risking it.
Okay, nice.
I'm playing it slow, guys!
It's like the safest here and if he sucks...
Ah!
No!
Oh no, this is bad.
This is actually bad, guys.
This is so bad.
I don't think I'm gonna kill him intact.
Guys, I think I might die here.
This is bad.
This is pretty bad.
I've stopped believing.
Guys!
I might stop believing here.
Okay.
Please!
How are you still so healthy?!
How?!
Please don't suck here.
Please don't.
Please.
I have so much HP!
Oh my god!
I mean, look at him.
Okay.
Please.
You're still so alive?!
Okay.
Please don't suck this tile.
Please.
This is my safest tile.
Look at all the pink lines!
Oh my god.
I can't use the bombs.
I don't trust myself.
Jesus!
He's still so healthy!
Okay.
Please don't suck this tile.
Please.
This is my only tile that I trust the most.
Oh my god!
Thank god!
Thank fucking god.
The one HP.
Yay!
Our two stars!
Yeah!
Easy.
So easy.
Wasn't even worried for a second, guys.
Pay your last respect.
Why did he put so much emphasis on his rear end?
Goodbye, king.
I'm the king now!
Goodbye!
Bro, his life was fucking shit.
That's right.
Yoink my soul now.
Yoki!
Please, pay some respect!
Crows don't need to pay respect.
Oh, I found a giant.
I don't want to be on the receiving end of one of these.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hello, Ms. Croaky.
This is Detective Smith.
He tripped and fell!
It's not my fault!
I found him like this.
He tripped and fell.
I think he got a heart attack.
I mean, look at him!
His cholesterol levels were so fucking high!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you.
I think I can go from here, right?
It's natural causes.
I'm just a crow.
Look how tiny I am compared to him.
You really think I can take him down?
Look at me.
He went to the heart attack grill.
Yeah, he went to the heart attack restaurant.
That's crazy that there's a restaurant dedicated to giving people heart attacks.
And you have to sign a waiver for them that they're not responsible for giving you a heart attack.
Even though that's the entire premise of the fucking restaurant.
Thank you for the five gifted strips.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, and it's perfectly legal too.
Oh, that's the fucked up part.
Wait, whose place is that?
That's somebody's new office.
Oh, no.
Okay, I need 300 more.
Okay, we gotta go back to the cemetery.
I don't remember where the pathway to that place again.
It's been a while.
I know I went the long way last time and I'm gonna do the long way again.
I guess I don't remember the not long way.
Unless it's here.
It's all the way down here.
No, that's not it.
I don't remember the not long way for this.
So I guess I'll go the long way again.
How strong am I?
Wait, I don't even one shot him?
I'm like so strong.
I put it all on strength.
Oh, it's going up.
That's... oh wait, but I have...
I went here for the...
obviously for the power up, guys.
Oh wait, no, it's money.
Okay.
I can finish this today.
I think it's like two more bosses or some shit.
I forgot, that's the... we gotta go to the door.
Which is like over here.
Hello, little guys.
Whoa.
Oh, get away from me.
Don't touch me.
Six feet.
There's the door.
Door should be right here, right?
Right here?
There's too many pathways.
I actually don't know where the final boss...
the third boss is, though.
Can't remember.
Let's see.
Am I going the right way?
Children.
Oh yeah, there it is.
Yeah, I am.
Hello, I have more souls for you.
Another astounding victory.
I'm impressed by your courage and vigor, fledgling.
Once again, I reiterate, I've been stuck here for such a long time.
Accomplished so little in comparison to you.
It's been like...
three days.
And you've been stuck here for how long?
You have given this old crow hope for the first time in many...
You must be really bad at your job.
This took me three days.
Just one more giant soul, and we can open Death's Door.
I suggest you head west.
That's left side!
Atop the mountain, you will meet an ancient beast of untold years.
Okay, wait.
So...
That's left.
So... I just go down?
Wait, no, it's this way.
Right?
Is it this way?
Yeah, it's this way.
Is it?
More left?
Wait, is there a secret here?
Any secrets?
No, no secrets.
Okay, and...
That's where the witch is.
So where's the...
So it's like this way?
Yeah?
No, that's up.
More left.
I know west is left because I'm on the left side.
So it should be here.
Oh, maybe it's this way.
Oh, yeah, there it is!
I don't think that's...
right, but like...
maybe?
This way.
The stranded sailor.
Does that remember west side?
I'm on the west coast, so I'm on the left side.
Oh, there we go!
I found it!
I'm so smart.
Wait!
The gods!
Praise be!
We gotta praise the bird Jesus!
Bird Jesus, how do I get to you?
Bird Jesus!
Don't worry, I have a power up now.
Boom!
That's five booms.
Oh my god, oh my god!
Don't mind me, I'm a big boy.
Wait a minute.
Why is he here?
Oh, fuck!
Oh, shit!
I got too greedy.
I got so greedy.
Please, I'm dead!
I just wanted to praise the bird Jesus.
How do I get back?
Oh no, I have to travel all the way back.
Okay, I remember how to go back.
Okay, look, he was so big that I just forgot how to play the game.
Just go left, like this way?
And just go this way and we'll be there.
Maybe?
I'm going left.
I wonder if he's like there.
Guys, I don't think going left works.
Guys, going left did not work, guys.
Yeah, he was so fucking huge, I just...
I just got stun locked.
Not gonna lie.
He like stunned me.
I was like, whoa!
Look at that fucking tank.
Wait, can I beat him up now?
Am I strong enough?
No.
I'm not strong enough.
Not that left?
Guys, you can't just say go left and then tell me it's not that left.
What?
There we go.
Okay, I figured it out.
Wait, no.
It's down here.
That's the witch.
And then down here was how I got there.
Okay, yeah.
I figured it out.
Now I'm there.
See guys, I figured it out.
It's the other left.
You're right, it's my other left.
It's okay.
Okay, we go this way.
Oh, Bird Jesus.
Don't worry, I know how to kill him now.
Not Bird Jesus, I would never.
That's blasphemy.
But the guy that's guarding Bird Jesus...
He's free.
He's free reign.
There you go.
Why is he so fast?
Jesus Christ.
Like he doesn't even care that I'm not there anymore.
He just wants to smash.
He doesn't even care.
He's just like, me smash.
Alright, nice.
Smashing done.
Okay, that was a lot easier.
I don't know how I died at the first.
Guys, I got stun locked, okay?
I got stun locked.
Hello Bird Jesus, I am here.
What is your wisdom?
Yay!
I need to find one more shard.
And then we go to the next boss.
The wild beast.
Roll, roll, roll.
We're almost there.
Before we go, I have to get...
Croaky needs water, I'll be right back.
I'm waking up every time I come back.
It's like, Croaky needs to get water in his sleep.
Alright.
Okay,
off we go.
Oh wait, there's boxes.
Are there any children in here?
Oh, there is.
Don't worry, I'm here to adopt you children.
Or you'll be used for HP.
Alright, off we go.
Hey, what's over here?
Nothing.
Okay, I can't do anything there yet.
Whoa.
Feels like they're gonna come alive.
Oh, they're like the other guards from the other area.
Maybe it's post-game.
Cause the witches guards didn't come alive.
Hello.
Wait, hey there!
What are you doing there, pothead?
Hello again, beak face.
How goes your adventure?
I'd like to stop by the Stranded Cellar to refresh my stocks of Jefferson's delicious soup.
He's an odd fellow, but a great chef.
Oh my god, what are you doing here?
Oh, I like the soundtrack for this one.
Secret?
What's secret?
I got a journal.
You found an adventure journal.
It's very damp.
The pages seem to be stuck together?
Hmm.
I'm not gonna question that.
Alright.
Where do I go?
Oh, I must have learned something here.
Cause I've seen all these anchors.
Oh wait, there's a door!
Door open.
Oh, there's another one.
What's this?
The grunt's old mask.
It seems this grunt is loyal to a new leader now.
Oh, that's you!
Wait, that's the guy I freed!
It's me!
Oh my god, it's...
The first...my first dragoon.
Right here.
The first dra...oh my god, I'm going...
I'm becoming famous.
Hello again, little bird.
Me come far and wide, see many thing.
World outside very beautiful.
Love, laugh, live.
The first dragoon.
That's all grunt want.
Oh my god.
He free man now.
Jefferson makes delicious soup.
He has dark secret not many people know.
But grunt saw straight away.
Jefferson not really professional chef.
But grunt no care.
Soup is delicious.
Oh, he don't judge.
Love, laugh, live.
The crow...
The first crow...
The first crow...you're right.
The first crow grunt.
Oh, this food.
Greetings fellow biped.
Jesus Christ, what the fuck?
My name is Jefferson.
A humble bartender and seafood enthusiast at your service.
Could these human hands prepare you a delicious meal?
Yeah, that's a...
That's a corpse controlled by a giant squid.
Also, Kodiak, welcome to tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
Great.
One delicious meal coming right up.
I sure do love preparing food with multi-digit hands.
Wait, is that his hand?
Wait a...
Whoa!
Am I eating him?
Now tell me...
Wait, wait a minute.
Is this a fetish?
He's giving me his parts.
Wait a minute.
I'm not here for your sick, twisted desires.
The worst part is that he gave this to me for free.
Now tell me, is it something while you ingest nutrients?
That doesn't make it sound better.
A secret lies submerged beneath the moat in the estate of the urn witch.
What?
The moat in the estate?
Opening it will require bringing an open flame to the east gardens.
Being a powerful witch's house lies a secret accessible from the west side.
To find it, you must look for openings in the hedges.
There's a lot going on in the witch's basement even before you reach the inner furnace.
A stray bow carriage may grant you access to its secrets.
That's all I have for you for now.
Okay, I don't think I'm gonna be accepting much soup after I...
Now that I know what it's made of.
This man like cut off his own hand for me to eat.
I can't do anything with the anchors yet.
I feel like I need a power-up for it.
Hello!
Hello there, fellow traveler.
Wait, it's the bard!
Go on, tell me how your soup is soup.
How's your adventure going?
Finding selling tales I can knock out a song about?
Reason being, I'm up in these here mountains seeking inspiration for my next masterpiece.
I heard a monster lives up in the mountaintops.
Can you believe it?
That drunk fella outside that's trying to sell her said he lost his love to the beast.
Fancy that.
The way I see it, there's gotta be one heck of an epic ballad awaiting me up ahead.
If only I could smash up these blasted rocks blocking the path.
Don't worry, a hero is here now.
Do not worry.
Boom!
Look at that, you smashed it!
You're a legend!
You might be an inspiration for my next big tune.
Yeah, if it's all the same to you, I might just tag along in your adventure.
See you around!
Don't no need to thank me.
You just gotta pay me.
I only take cash.
Ha ha ha ha ha!
My service- Oh, child!
My services do not come for free.
Alright, let's see.
I'm gonna go downstairs.
I always get confused on where to go first.
I wonder if there's like, hidden stuff in the crystals.
Or are they just here for like, child?
I'm just gonna break every crystal just in case.
No, actually, no.
I have too many children.
I don't think I need more, right?
Wait, is this the correct path?
No, that's...
door.
Oh, wait.
It's the Frozen Fortress.
Wait, is this the correct path?
Or like...
Or is there like more... Or is it...
It is?
Okay, we gotta go this way then.
I'm gonna go this way.
Cause I didn't go right side.
I got... There's too many pathways.
Let's see.
Is there a secret?
Secret?
No secret?
Why take me here?
I have no secret.
Anything up here?
Any secret?
No secret!
Nice.
And we go down here.
Money.
Okay, and then I can slam dunk here.
It's slam dunk time.
Watch this.
Where I go?
Where does this take me?
Where is this area?
Oh, Bird Jesus!
Hello, Bird Jesus!
I come for wisdom!
What do you have for me?
Oh, I should get vitality!
Magic, ready?
Yeah!
Magic!
Oh, shit.
Now I have five.
Praise be!
Praise be, Bird Jesus!
Now where am I?
Is it this way?
Oh yeah, it's this way.
Yeah, so that was the correct path.
Alright, up I go.
Up I go.
Praise be, Bird Jesus!
Boy, you're so generous.
Generous to all bird kind.
How is this a puzzle?
That is not a puzzle.
Cool.
Nice.
I just like hit stuff.
Wait, is there...
Can I light this?
No.
Oh, it teaches me the area's mechanics.
Oh!
Oh, I almost have 1500.
Hey again, pal!
I hope you don't mind me tagging along.
Seems like we'll need to find a way through this old fortress if we want to get up that mountain.
When I say we...
Wait, it's just like me for real for real.
When I say we, I mean you.
I just hang around here and work on the lyrics for our next banging tune.
Let me know you find a way up.
Oh my God, he's just like me.
When I say we.
Okay.
Oh, there's a lot of areas to go.
Oh my God.
Which way do I go first?
Oh my God, I'm overwhelmed already.
I'll go left side.
Left cause west.
Okay.
I just went in a straight line.
Whoops.
Whoops, my bad.
Oh, okay.
I get it.
Come down, and then...
I'm so smart.
Okay, that was useless.
I gotta figure out how to unlock that, I guess.
Wait, what?
How do I unlock it?
Where's the unlock button?
What?
How do I unlock?
Okay.
I'll just run around.
Look, it was a smart thing that I do.
Okay, guys.
I just didn't know how to unlock.
See, I unlocked this.
Smart bird.
Hello.
Oh my God, first monster.
Oh, fuck.
I'm just the first one to fight today.
I don't know his mechanics.
Boom.
Five booms.
Fire!
Okay, nice.
Oh, there's more.
Okay, there's more.
Oh, no, not the green man.
No, not him.
I need to get him out of here.
He needs to die first.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
I'm just gonna use bomb for him.
I'm not getting close to that guy.
I realized that maybe I need to start upgrading magic.
Now.
Oh.
After strength, I upgrade magic.
Because I'm just using magic for these guys.
Maybe I told you.
No, you didn't.
I selectively did not read it.
There we go.
Easy.
Alright, hello.
I'm here to free you.
It's so cold.
My bad.
Oh my god.
That's a cold ass door.
Maybe going all strength wasn't it, guys?
Who would've thought?
Maybe Maybe all strength is not the answer.
Who could've known?
Okay, let's do this.
How do I use the anchor?
What?
Okay, we go up.
We go up.
Child.
Oh, wait.
Okay.
Where does this take me?
Hello.
Secret tunnel.
Okay, nice.
Money.
I always need that.
And then...
Child.
Where does this area take me to?
There's so many different entrances and exits.
Oh.
Okay.
Is that open?
Okay, I opened that gate.
Croaky learning.
Yeah, it's a whole fucking maze.
I'm not good with mazes.
This is...
Where am I?
Okay, that's a grave.
Light this up.
Oh?
That's a new thing.
Wait, did I miss another one?
Wait, where was...
Oh, hey, hello.
Oh my god, that's you.
Hello, sir.
You created my job.
And now I'm stuck to work.
And I can never die.
So I'm stuck to work forever.
So I guess...
Thank you?
No, fuck you!
That's right.
Fuck you!
This is the...
I guess I hate you.
This is the resting place of weed.
The lord of doors.
God!
I hate you!
You created my job!
I was supposed to be a free bird!
Now crow has to get job!
It's the resting place of weed.
The lord of doors.
I am lord Lockstone for whom this crypt was named.
We lord of doors were anomaly.
A mistake of the universe some might say.
Yeah, fuck yeah, a mistake of my life.
But is that not an apt description of all life?
A mistake of the croaky going punk now.
A mistake of the universe, one which grows and thrives.
A system was born in sick consciousness.
And to preserve that consciousness is the most important and noble goal.
He created labor laws for crows.
Crows never needed jobs.
Stupid fucking man.
Created corporate.
Okay, we go this way.
This is fine.
Nice.
Where'd he go?
Get outta here.
Croaky mad.
Croaky has to get a 9 to 5.
Okay.
Oh my god, I keep forgetting the bomb guy.
Jesus Christ.
Stupid bomb guy.
Okay, nice.
I have my own bomb!
That's fucking ri- oh shit!
Okay.
Whoops.
Oh shit, he's back.
Oh no, he's back.
Okay,
nice.
Get outta here.
Jesus, it took me like- Oh my god, he got too close.
Okay, nice.
He dead.
I'm getting better, guys.
See, look at that.
I'm getting better.
Hello.
Entombed alongside the old lords.
I suppose some would call it an honor.
I would call it a tragedy.
The only way to stop working is to die.
Truly, a sad crotale.
You'd never stop working until you're dead!
Ah!
What a sad tale.
No retirement, no benefits, no pension.
Let's see, we go this way.
And then...
Thank you for the super chat!
Chat, it's lunch time for me!
What do I eat?
Subway or burger?
Or could I deep-fire this funny-looking chicken on the side of my screen?
Thank you for the super chat!
I'm gonna say there's like a tomb here.
You should get a burger!
Get a burger!
How did I get that?
Is there like, any tombs?
Any tombs for me to light up?
Because there's like four!
I guess not here.
Oh, I guess not.
There's no tombs here.
Okay, I'm back here then.
I don't know, I thought there might be like a grave somewhere.
Oh, I can level up.
Nah, I'm gonna level up my magic, actually.
Actually, hmm...
Oh, it's so far!
Oh my god, why is it so far from the office?
Ho ho ho!
Hello!
Free crows?
We can do that?
We don't have to work outside the commission.
Free- that's- that's a thing!
Free crows?
Oh my god.
It was a choice?!
I can choose?!
Okay.
Um...
Okay, but I could max- I'm gonna max it out.
You know, I was like, I'm gonna max it out.
But look how strong- look at these bicep-septo guys!
Look at these abs!
Whoa!
I couldn't help it!
I wanted- I wanted those abs!
Yeah!
Can't believe it was a choice all along.
Understandable.
Did I say there's like extra pots to break?
I don't see any, because I want to break that area.
Yeah, there's nothing I could like break here.
Because I want to break- I need to use that stone, but I have no energy.
No energy.
Is it here?
I should reset my magic, too.
Honestly.
Uh...
We'll go this way.
Hello, is there anything here?
Oh, that's the doors!
Oh!
Oh, I can use this here to reset my magic, though.
Okay, I have a slam dunk somewhere here.
Okay, now I have enough energy for...
uh...
for the...
the little blockade back at Reaper home.
Door open.
I missed a child, but I guess he's gonna be an orphan forever.
Goodbye.
Oh, that's life.
This appears to be a Reaper's abandoned logbook.
The recent seismic event has sent upper management into a frenzy.
You've been ordered to scrub all mentions of it from record and close all active assignments in the region.
I can in good conscience let all those Reapers remain cut off from the commission and their homes.
I'm gonna try making my way into the vicinity, see if I can help them.
Aww.
He dead.
He still is now used to power up my doors.
I'll make it back in one piece.
I'll update my logs to indicate what I found.
There are no more entries in this journal.
Aww, he dead.
But look at this cool item I found.
I found a surf- Oh my god, that's the thing that's inside my body.
Hahahaha.
He found a surveillance device.
It looks like someone has been spying on the commission.
Oh my god, there's my spy drone that the government installed.
Alright, let's go back now.
Todd, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you.
I'm like a snake.
I can- Yeah, it might be bigger than me, but it's- I'm like a snake.
I unhook- I un- unlock my beak.
And go, ahhhh.
Ah, ah.
I like the baby birds either.
Yeah, and hinge the beak.
Hahahaha.
That's how- that's how they do it.
Have you never seen a crow unhinge their beaks?
I went the wrong way.
Oh nice, I'm okay now.
Wait, how do I- Do I go faster?
Oh, I do.
I was gonna say, do I go faster than this?
Okay, where's the next one?
Oh, I have to go this way.
It's fine, I'm faster than the thingy.
I'll just use my arrow.
Oh shit.
Last one's here.
There you go.
Croaky as- What?
That's how baby birds eat!
They're like, Mom!
Mom!
And then the mom comes in and throws up in their baby mouth.
Blah blah.
It's not gross, it's just nature!
Uncultured goons.
It's literally how birds eat!
Can't believe you're judging my lifestyle.
It's fucked up.
I didn't know they like-
Okay.
I didn't know which part has to wait.
Oh my god.
Okay.
There we go.
Where's the last one?
It's all the way there.
It's like those children that like never we- It's like the mammal children, you know, like human kids.
Have you guys ever read those articles where like there's like kids that never grew up?
I refuse to elaborate.
Oh shit!
I'm sorry!
Punishment for my crimes.
A dragoon sent sent somebody to punish me.
For the crimes I've committed in this stream.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I'm on HP.
Where are my children?
Oh, he does like two hits.
Okay.
I think I'm dead.
I think I might be dead.
Maybe.
Does not look ideal for me right now.
Okay.
I should be able to kill this guy really fast though.
No, I'm definitely dead.
Oh fuck!
Oh shit!
No, I'm definitely dead.
Oh.
Oh, he's just running.
Oh!
Okay, nice.
He does like two swings and I have to remember that.
Okay.
Is that a second swing?
Okay, yeah.
Oh, he did!
He tried to do a third swing!
You freak!
Here lies Lord Theodore, the first successor in the lineage of lords.
Their transition to power was smooth, and their reign egalitarian.
Remember, for their fair nature, enforcing better working conditions for reapers.
You still made us work!
We could be free girls!
What do you mean better conditions?
We didn't have jobs before!
We didn't understand the concept of money!
At least they unionized.
Alright, we go this way.
Oh wait, we go that way.
I forgot about your soul, sorry.
Don't worry, I got your soul.
My life is ending, but this lord plans to live forever.
Doesn't feel fair to me.
Goodbye.
Welcome to corporate.
Life's not fair!
Alright, let's...
Wait, is that?
No, that's not a pathway.
I had to double check.
How do I get over there?
What?
There's clearly a pathway for it.
Huh?
Oh, I can't right now.
Okay.
Confused crow.
Okay, I guess I won't do it then.
Don't have to talk to a dead boss.
My dead CEO.
Oh...
Where am I at?
Is there a child here?
Nice.
Child!
See?
You get to be adopted.
I can just walk around.
Like...
What the fuck?
How is that a threat?
Wait, can I swing?
Can I?
Okay.
Look, I thought there was invincibility if I framed.
I thought there'd be iframes.
How the fuck was I supposed to know?
I don't know.
Why didn't it work this time?
Okay, I pick up a key.
I'll be like, maybe I can iframe this.
Clearly could not.
Clearly won't let me iframe this.
Oh, wait.
Okay.
Go this way.
There's two ways.
Where's the other door go?
What does this one go to?
What?
Where am I going?
Wait, where is this taking Croaky?
Long secret tunnel.
Oh, wait, this is...
Wait, no, that's just a relic.
No, I choose money.
That's just...
That's just a collectible.
I pick money.
Crows need to pay rent.
Alright.
Yay, rent money.
Okay, nice.
Look, I can do it.
I cannot do it again.
Oh, I can.
Nice.
Oh, I can do it again.
I'll say again.
Okay.
Alright, now Croaky go get a collectible.
Money first.
Exactly.
Of course, Croaky.
Money shiny.
Okay, then we go here.
Then we go here.
And it leads me to the area I have to go anyway.
Nice.
I got it.
I found an ancient crown.
It feels unusual to touch as it once contained life.
Okay, nice.
Alright, pick up the child.
Get adopted.
Alright, open door time.
Living reaper, bring me energy.
Wait, what?
Am I missing?
One more.
Oh, there.
I didn't see it.
I was missing one.
Whoops.
Alright.
This way.
I didn't go this way yet.
Wait, did I go this way?
No, I did.
I came back from here.
Wait a minute.
I came from here.
Wait, but I went this way.
I'm confused.
Where do I go?
The right side?
This one?
Did I not go this way?
No, I went this way before.
Did I miss something?
Yeah, I came from here.
Yeah, this is where I killed those people.
Cool.
Yeah.
Coal key lost.
Which way do I go?
Huh?
Got a key.
Where does key unlock?
Wait, what?
I got a key.
Oh, wait.
No, that's where...
Oh my god, where the fuck does my key open?
There's a locked door somewhere.
I have a lock.
Oh, there it is.
Oh my god, I found it.
Okay, I had to backtrack.
Bad seed.
Okay, I figured it out, guys.
This is where I killed the last guy.
Oh!
Wait, what?
How did I kill him?
What happened?
How did I kill the other guy?
Oh god, not him.
Oh, and I missed.
He does one more swing.
What?
I got greedy.
Boom!
I got way too greedy there.
Why does it still swing three times?
I'm so strong!
Look at my abs!
Oh, not him.
Not him.
Oh, fuck.
Where is he coming from?
Get over here!
No!
I have to kill this guy!
He's the scariest one of them all!
Nice.
He dead.
Okay, we got three crows.
Or four crows, don't worry.
I free you.
Posted in this fortress, I have learned a great deal about the old lord of the doors.
Still don't much care for them.
We should've started a union.
Rise up, crows!
We gotta unionize!
Okay.
Go home now?
Yeah, we can.
And then I eat my children.
And then we go home.
We go all the way back.
How much do I have?
Okay, 400.
I need 200 more for upgrades.
It's this way.
I remember it's this way.
We gotta unionize!
We gotta become free crows again!
I don't need to be careful.
I consent!
I don't even think we have healthcare insurance here.
Alright, here we go.
Avarice.
Wait, there's fire now?
Woah!
I didn't see him!
It's so dark!
Oh my god, they're too close.
They're just running.
Okay, nice.
Okay, I need to get this guy out of here.
I don't have time to use the heavy attacks!
Ah!
Fuck!
I can only use like the small attacks.
Because they move too fast!
It's not fair!
Okay, nice.
We got what?
Two flames.
Oh no, not these guys.
Not these guys.
Okay, okay.
Oh my god, try to hit the jar!
Okay, this is it.
Oh my god!
I'm just gonna use my hands.
That's awkward.
Oh my god, it's him!
Oh my god!
Bro, he's so scary!
He's so big!
Oh!
He's so scary, I don't wanna get close to him.
Oh thank god!
He's the scariest of them all.
Okay, now I should have the anchor ability now.
Crow Jesus!
Crow God!
Praise be!
I give to a fellow crow to aid you on your quest.
Crow God!
Praise be!
Lord of the crows.
Oh my god, I'm royalty now.
See that crown?
The hookshot, press to use it.
How much does it use?
Oh my gosh!
Now I'm royalty!
Praise be!
Crow God!
You granted me royal blood.
Oops.
Okay, I was scared that I was gonna fuck it up again.
Oh, I can use it for the lamp!
Oh!
Wait, it doesn't use any abilities.
Nice.
I didn't read the journal.
Oh wait, I can go upstairs again.
What does the journal say?
They're getting too close to the truth!
They get crazy!
They get a little cuckoo!
Oh!
Ooh!
I'm glad that this doesn't take like...
extra...
Doesn't take extra magic points to...
Hey, there's a phone!
Ring ring!
Oh wait, this is where I started!
Look at that, the dwarves propaganda.
The corporate propaganda to make me feel like a happy worker.
That Vaga reckons that something big's gonna happen here soon.
You know anything about that, buddy?
No, I'm just a crow.
Okay.
Oh, hello kids.
I don't know why anyone was complaining.
These things are adorable and they like the same TV shows as me.
Oh, look at that!
They're sleeping!
Wake up!
Corporate propaganda.
I'm just relaxing, feeding the birds.
But none of my friends want to eat off the floor.
You get to pick to be a free bird.
This is fucked up.
Why can't I pick?
Wait, not this way.
Okay, I need to...
Do I have enough?
I need nine points.
Wait!
What?
Why is it black now?
What did you...
What did you do to it?
Oh!
He got in the ink supply.
The poor deer.
Although she doesn't seem to mind.
Maybe she just loves the smell of ink as much as I do.
I was like, it changes color?
I was like, wow!
You can do that?
Change color now.
Change color.
I was like, what the fuck?
A thing?
Oh my god!
Oh no!
It got into the supply!
I don't remember where that needs anchors.
I don't remember.
I'm trying to think.
Wait, we gotta get money first.
Oh my god, there's so many backtracks.
I'm not backtracking, guys.
I remember there's like a lot of areas that have anchors in the other areas, but we're not backtracking.
And we need to go this way.
And then this way.
There's an anchor here.
There's a tomb here with the anchors.
What is this?
I lied.
This was not it.
I backtracked here for no reason.
God fucking- Okay.
I went all the way here for no reason.
God damn it, okay.
Okay, it's this way.
And then, was there a back- There's this- Were there anchors here, right?
Oh yeah, there was.
Okay, I figured it out.
That's where the anchors were.
These are so many.
There's no mini-map.
Okay?
I have to rely on my- Ah!
Shit.
Okay.
There's no mini-map.
I have to use my crow brain.
Crows have an IQ of a nine-year-old.
Nine-year-olds don't remember things like these.
What do I do with this key?
I have an extra key.
Why do nine-year-olds have to remember this?
Are there any extra anchors here?
Maybe extra anchors here.
Alright.
Get away, children!
Okay, no.
Not here.
That's my dead crow friend.
Get away, kids.
Daddy's trying to fucking think right now.
And it's not working so well.
Oh, there you go.
Okay, I figured it out.
Huh?
Okay.
Why...
Why is there one over here?
I'm confused why there's one randomly here.
Oh, there's how I got the money.
How do I...huh.
How do I get over here?
Okay, we found money.
Like, why is there one here?
When I could just grapple this.
Okay, we don't...we did that.
Oh my god, where else do I have to go?
Where else?
I don't know.
Oh, there, there, there!
Okay, I know.
I know now.
And then I open door.
Okay.
And then it opens.
Okay, it does a ladder.
Okay.
I know now.
What?
I am at appropriate height!
Excuse me!
Huh?
Oh.
Now I'm at appropriate height!
Okay.
I figured it out.
I'm at appropriate height now.
Okay, I need to think about this.
Okay.
Did I do that?
What?
What is appropriate height?
I'm at appropriate height?
Okay, here.
What did I do?
Oh!
Okay.
And then...
Ah.
Um.
I can't hit that.
Ah.
Okay, think.
Okay, smart.
So smart.
I have to do this again.
And then...
Oh my god, my brain is so smart.
The smartest nine-year-old out there.
Open door.
The smartest nine-year-old bird out there.
What's this?
Wait, I could've gone this way this entire...
Wait, no.
This is different.
Yeah.
Speed!
Okay, there.
Where does this take me?
Ah, another grave!
I don't wanna read this.
Wait, but that...
That fucks with my job!
Why would you extend life when my whole job is to delete life?
That doesn't make sense!
What's the point of my job if you're just gonna extend life?
Fuck you!
Oh, your life was not easy!
I live forever!
At least you get to die!
Die!
The balance of the universe was my duty and mine alone.
The lord who created me had grand illusions about fate and purpose.
But fate did not buy me the death's door.
Title drop.
Duty did.
No other could take... It's like when the CEO of...
The CEO of a retailer or a superstore or whatever and they're like telling it to their workers at the stores.
You think you have it bad?
I gotta make financial decisions for that company as this person is working their fifth job right now of the day.
Controlling life and death so I bore the burden.
I bore it for as long as I could even extending my life beyond the bounds set by pitiful anarchism that is death.
My time finally drew to a close.
My successor paid no heed to my teachings.
I fear their reign may have destroyed the balance I tried so hard to maintain.
What a bitter disappointment they have been.
Greatness is seldom free, crow.
True greatness may even cost you your soul.
You get to die!
I have to work this job forever!
Hello.
Where am I?
Wait, I don't think I ever went this way.
Secret!
And I went this way.
There's like a hidden door.
Oh, it's just fucking collectible.
You found some kind of signed contract?
How exciting!
Sure.
That's what they all say about contracts.
That's it?
Huh.
Thought I'd get something more out of that.
Thought I'd be praying that birds use this again.
Oh boy, I'm on DA.
Oh, there's the door.
Oh,
that's where it takes me.
Okay.
Do I have 600 now?
Oh, I do!
My magic can be a little stronger now.
Uh...
Please upgrade my magic, sir.
Yes.
I would like to upgrade my magic.
Strengthen magic.
Think I can, guys.
If I could, I would have most definitely put in more strength, guys.
You know I would.
I want an 8-pack.
8-pack.
Oh, shit.
Wrong area.
If I could, I would put more.
Alright.
Up I go.
Was it this way?
Oh yeah, it was.
There's the ladder.
Yeah, now I get bronze and brains.
Whoa!
That's like seeing a crow climb up the ladder.
It's so silly.
The way he climbs up.
Such a silly guy.
Why'd he, like, reset it?
I have to do this again.
I like how the range is really far, too.
I like that.
I have to do this again?
No, thank God.
I was like, please no.
Was there anything else I missed from this area?
I don't remember.
No, it was just his grave.
Okay.
Go this way, then.
Unlock!
I'm very confused.
I'm very confused, guys.
Oh,
shit.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Let me go get some kids real quick.
I got confused!
I'm sorry!
You know, fuck it, if I die, I die.
Okay.
I got confused.
My crow of mind did not know what to think.
What?!
I thought it blocked it!
The lasers go so fast!
It went too fast.
And I didn't know what to think.
Okay.
It went too fast.
Crow brain couldn't comprehend the speed.
I was trying to think.
Like, what do I...
Like, what?
Oh!
Okay, I figured it out.
Okay, I figured it out, guys.
Oh my God.
Crow key is so smart.
I just had to die once.
Ah!
Fuck!
Okay, I got a little over...
I got a little too excited.
Guys.
I got way too excited.
Okay, this is not fair.
This is actually not fair.
It, like, goes...
Oh my God, I, like, gripped the wrong one.
I need to be more patient.
I realize.
Guys, it's because I forgot to be patient, okay?
I, like, got a little too excited.
I, like, went too fast.
Don't you hate it when you go too fast?
There we go.
Gotta go fast.
But sometimes you don't gotta go fast.
Okay, nice.
Wait, this is just the other tomb.
Alright.
Where's the last one?
Oh?
Wait, but where's the last one?
Hello?
I have no business in.
If opportunities present itself, child, ending the cycle will be what is right for the universe.
My lifetime was too short to come to that ultimate conclusion.
But I remain hopeful that others will reach it on their own.
Just a crow.
Why you tell me this?
Okay.
We go this way.
HP.
Wait, can I do it again?
Okay.
Okay, wait, wait.
Come on.
Wake up, little kids.
Wake up.
Oh, we've always had two kids, guys.
What do you mean?
There's always been two, guys.
It's always been two.
Hello?
Nah.
Wait, where's the last one?
Did I do everything?
Is there an anchor over here that I missed?
Must have missed an anchor here.
Yeah, there's one up here.
Oh, there's one up here.
Okay.
Okay, and then...
Alright,
last grave.
Okay, where's the last one?
Okay, I got this.
What happened?
Oh, it's this way.
Oh, this way.
Oh wait, this is easier.
What the fuck?
This one's so easy.
Compared to what I had to do.
Open the door!
Let me in!
Nice.
Alright, and then...
Light the fire.
Which one are you?
Dragons, I'm sad.
I waited five and a half hours for the secret casting chair to reveal in the Avengers Doomsday cast announcement video.
Hopefully she'll show up in the secret wars.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh yeah, I saw that on Twitter.
They kept hyping up being like, the reveal would be even bigger than the Robert Downey Jr. Doctor Doom reveal.
I was just like, and the people that sat there and just watched this fucking video of them slowly revealing casting chairs one by one by one.
And I was like, that's a...
Who's got the time for that?
What was the reveal, guys?
I was just gonna wait until...
Apparently Carl does.
I'm sorry, Carl.
What was the reveal that was supposed to be even bigger than Robert Downey Jr.?
Here lies Lord Opengate, the third in the lineage of the Lords.
Their rule was steady and without hindrance.
A skilled delegation that spent many of their years expanding their knowledge while traveling the vastness of space.
Like, anyone actually import it?
New outfit?
The fuck does that mean?
I have not paid attention to...
Oh my god, I remember last time I trash talked Marvel Cinematic Universe and I had one person in my...
in the comments that got really mad about it.
Saying how Marvel movies are like one of the best movies out there.
And I'm like, you gotta watch more movies.
I'll say maybe in the beginning, but post Avengers?
Post like...
What was it?
Post...
The Endgame?
I don't think so.
Greetings, young Reaper.
Your presence here is quite a conundrum.
It will indicate that the course of events which started with the formation of Death's Door has led the universe to bring a great peril.
However, it is also indicative of those actions correcting themselves.
Oh no, I would say... Okay.
I told you guys.
I got really bored of like, Marvel movies very, very early on.
I've never watched Captain America.
I've never watched any of the Avengers movies other than Endgame.
I've only... I watched Guardians... I actually really like Guardians of the Galaxy because I love the director.
I think the director is a really... I love his directing style, so I've always like, watched like, majority of his stuff.
Especially like, what he's doing with DC right now.
And like, I never watched Captain America.
I heard Captain America 1 was pretty good, but like, I got really tired of superhero movies from the MCU a very long time ago.
Yeah, I love James Gunn's stuff.
I love his stuff.
I love what he did for the...
What is it called?
The...
Um... The Suicide Squad one, but for the Monsters...
Oh, I forgot what it's called.
The animated show?
It's really... I personally really enjoyed it.
I was so surprised with like...
Ha ha ha!
Like, I was so surprised with like, some of the writing they did for it.
Because it was like, so...
They had like, really good plot twists and stuff.
And also that moment when...
Um... Uh...
Oh my god, what was that?
The GI robot?
Ha ha ha!
You know that scene where he was like...
Huh...
Ha ha ha!
That was so good!
What was the... Creature Commandos!
Yeah, yeah.
If you like superhero stuff, I highly recommend checking out Creature Commandos.
Yeah, no, James Gunn!
Yeah, he did!
He worked on that.
Yeah.
And like, they're expanding the...
They're gonna base the new...
They're gonna base the new DC, I guess like...
The DC Cinematic Universe.
They're gonna base off the DC Cinematic Universe off of Creature Commandos and stuff.
Uh... Ha ha ha!
Which is pretty crazy to think about.
So they're revamping the entire story off of Creature Commandos.
Cause that's canon now.
Uh...
Life is merely the universe experiencing itself.
And that's it.
I just like James Gunn's stuff in general.
I think he's a very talented director and writer.
Uh...
And I also love... What was it called?
The one with... The one with John Cena?
Um... Peacemaker!
I like that one.
That show.
Cause he directed that too.
We as parts of it are all acting to maintain that balance.
Stay true to your path, young reaper.
And I can sense victory in your future.
I like Peacemaker.
That was a really good show too.
And that's directed by James Gunn as well.
Whoa!
Into the hole I go!
Where did I... Where did I go?
I don't remember where his body was.
Oh, that's where his body was.
Solid!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Master Sky Croaky.
What are we going to do now?
Croaky likes super activation noise.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
John Cena has always been a really good actor.
Compared... And then The Rock is like the opposite spectrum of that.
Hey, you got that old elevator working.
The Rock literally just plays himself.
John Cena is actually acting.
I just finished the next chapter of my song.
Yeah, I wanna hear your song.
Here we go!
That's not a mask!
That's a part of your head!
Tell you a tale as old as time.
A classic repeating paradigm.
A mating trapped at the peak of our climb.
Don't judge him.
Her fishman love driven out of his mind.
The hero will right the wrongs of his crime.
That's me.
I'm hero.
That it?
That was a song.
Alright, then I'll meet you further up the mountain.
Don't get into trouble on the way.
At least not without me.
It was a song, guys.
I won't say it was a good song, but it was a song.
I spent all that time writing that.
Alright, let's see.
This way.
Wait, where am I?
Where is Croaky?
Oh, I'm up top!
Back to see.
Oh, I'm up here now!
Is there anything here?
A secret?
No secret.
We gotta go this way.
Phew!
What the fuck?
In his final breaths, he slapped me.
Okay.
We gotta grab some money.
Is there anything here?
No, there's nothing there.
I don't need a learn to fly.
I have my hook.
Okay, we gotta go up here.
I can't believe he slapped me before he died.
I'm so fucked up.
Only I can slap.
Who gave that guy rights to slap?
Can I use this to hurt him?
Oh!
Okay, that's scary.
Okay.
Okay, now I know a kid does that.
Okay, I learned.
Oh, there's seeds.
Hello, children.
I will not send you to your deaths.
Don't worry.
I don't know if I'll ever do that.
Why would I ever have to get close to them?
Is there something here?
Oh wait, no.
Never mind.
I thought I could go across that wall.
Walk in the straight line.
Cause there's fall damage.
Hello?
Oh, children.
Doink.
My child now.
Unhand me.
You're coming with me.
No way to get to that side door.
Wait, do I have enough?
No, I don't.
I don't have enough for upgrades.
Do I have an extra key?
No.
Wait.
There's crows?
Welcome to free crows?
Free?
Old friend.
We knew you'd make it here eventually.
Oh my god.
The stories were real.
They were real.
They don't have to work on the farm cause it was all real.
Even you need a bit of guidance along the way.
Hehehehe.
We are a group of free thinking.
You get to think for free?
You don't have to tell your supervisor what you're thinking about today?
Hahahahaha.
We reject the ideas of the lord of the doors.
We do not want unnatural mortality if it must come at the cost of our lives.
What is the point in living forever if it is to be a slave?
No, we choose to live free and die free.
So go, climb ever higher.
Defeat the beast at the top of the mountain and claim its soul.
Oh, but make sure you're well prepared before you head onwards.
Remember, you're welcome here anytime you like.
Oh my god.
It's real.
The stories are true.
Why are you free if you wear clothes?
Hahahahaha.
Welcome, foretold crow.
We have a simple life here, foraging and living off the land.
We even use fur shed by the beasts atop the mountain as bedding.
I don't understand if we're free, why you wear clothes?
Hahahahaha.
You can be whoever you wanna be.
We all abandon our assignments, which means our life now ticks away.
However, we are happier for it.
This is the way it should be.
Without death, new life cannot grow.
Look, I'm not wearing clothes.
Oh wait, no, I'm wearing pants.
Hahahahaha.
Foretold crow, it is an honor to meet you.
Did you find any of our shrines on your journey?
It seems there are still ten shrines you have yet to find.
I'm sure they will help you on your journey in the fight with the beasts.
I don't need that.
I don't need shrines.
I'm going in.
How do I kidnap this child?
Oh, it's here.
Okay, nice.
Greetings, foretold crow.
This is a gate of knowledge.
Its eyes see all things.
Its heart knows all things.
Its soul exists in all things.
It whispers to us that when we need guidance, it foretold your arrival and your destiny.
What does it do?
How do I turn it on?
I can't believe it.
Is there something I can take off my pants when I become a free crow?
Okay, here we go.
Where do I go?
Oh, there's the bard.
Oh my god, that has a crow head.
Okay, I'll go up.
Hello, bard.
Phew.
It's quite a steep climb getting up here.
My pipes are still wheezing.
You must be pleased I punched though, huh?
I mean, a secret crow society?
Wait, how do you know about the secret crow society?
And they have so many great stories about their lives up here.
Especially about the beast on top of the mountain.
Yeah, I'm getting so much inspiration on our adventure.
I think my next song might be the greatest I've ever written.
And I've written more than five.
Oh my god, so fucking talented you are.
Alright, I'll go this way then.
Feels like this is...
The frozen canyon.
Ooh.
That sounds exciting.
How does that take me?
Okay.
I understand now.
Okay, I understand.
Wait, what?
Wait, why would I have to...
Huh.
Oh no, it's just like Crash Bandicoot.
Whee!
Wait, but like...
Oh.
Woah,
woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah.
Woah.
Is it worth it?
Woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah.
Okay.
Wait, is this worth it?
I don't think it's worth it, right?
Okay, this is hard.
This is actually really hard.
This is hard.
Oh.
God damn.
Not one HP.
Wait, this is so difficult.
Okay.
Okay, nice.
Wait, but is it even worth it?
I can't tell.
Oh, one HP and a dream.
No!
Okay.
Oh, okay, I get it.
I get it now.
I get it.
But do you really get it, Croaky?
Okay.
This first, and then...
WHAT?!
Okay, that's fucked up.
Okay, I did it too fast.
I did it too fast, but I get it now.
Okay.
Now I got this.
There we go.
And then I drop...
down.
Okay, I got a little scared.
I'm not gonna lie.
I did get a little scared there.
I wanna know...
Okay.
That's fucked.
That's...
Okay, I wanna know if I can...
grab it.
No, I can't.
Okay.
Okay, I gotta...
Oh my god.
Oh.
No!
That's so fucked up!
Oh my god!
Okay.
I do it here.
It was just for that?!
That's all it was?!
I don't even have...
I don't even have enough!
I don't even...
Oh my god.
I can't believe...
that was what it was for.
I can't believe it.
I thought it would be something cooler.
It could have given me like...
two at least.
I don't even get...
plus one HP.
I'm going in there with one...
Fuck it.
I'm going in there with one HP.
Let's go.
But the experience...
Fuck it.
We're doing it live.
There must be children up here.
There's always kids.
Come on.
Where are the kids?
Where can I plant...
the children?
Wait, I might be able to get my HP back.
Alright.
In through door, out through door.
Yes, alright.
Thank god.
I recharged my HP.
Okay.
Do I have to go this way?
I have to go down.
Right?
Yeah.
Boom!
Nice.
Okay.
Alright.
Look at that boss music for the last round.
I think it has...
I don't know if this would be the last...
There has to be one more level after this.
After the beast.
But I feel very...
motivated right now to kill.
Boom.
Me first.
Okay.
Nice.
Why is there so many hook areas?
It must be the last guy to kill.
Oh, there you go!
Look at that!
Children!
Woah!
Don't worry.
Don't worry, kids!
I planted the seed!
Why is there so many hooks?
What am I hooking for?
Feel my spirit, children!
Oh, what the fuck?
He dodges.
Wait, he's not supposed to do that.
Okay.
Boom!
Get the safety.
Don't worry, I'll protect you.
I am a protector.
Oh, I can't open this yet.
Don't worry, children!
I'll definitely protect you.
Oh, shit.
I didn't protect myself first.
Boom.
Oh, he missed.
Stupid.
Oh, fuck!
Okay, maybe...
Okay, nice.
Okay, the lasers kill.
That's good to know.
Wait, can they hurt me from here?
Ow!
Yes, they can.
Fuck!
Oh my god, fuck!
Okay.
I'm gonna use the laser to my advantage.
There we go.
I lived!
Okay, I'm going back to the kids.
Give me a sec.
Children!
Krooky needs health!
Get over here!
I lived!
Thank god.
Alright.
I climb up.
I go down.
Oh, there he is.
Come down here and fight me!
Stupid whore!
Come down here!
That's where I'm talking about you!
All he can go is back and forth.
So fucking stupid.
Okay.
Okay,
nice.
Wait, is that...
Wait, come down.
Oh, fuck!
Not like that!
Is that what I meant?
Not fair.
What the fuck?
What is the range?
What the fuck was that range?
Okay, that was bullshit though.
That was absolutely bullshit.
And where do I go?
What?
Oh.
Supposed to go down.
Okay, there's too many anchors.
I'm getting disoriented.
Okay, and then we got shortcut.
Shortcut.
How did you get there?
Why didn't you open the lever?
What the fuck?
You could've opened the lever!
Dang, the weather sure is rough here.
The wind's just howling through my pipes.
Still, a bit of bad weather's never deterred me before, especially with a beast so close now.
I wonder what it looks like.
Based on what the crow said, it sounds like a proper monster.
All hairy and wild.
I can't wait to see you fight it.
I literally had to fucking go through so many hooks to get there.
Sorry to tap out.
Oh, elevator.
I was a little confused.
Okay, that's another shortcut I have to open soon.
Bomb!
Boom!
Whoops.
I forgot about the platforms.
My bad.
There's no way he can fly.
I refuse to believe he can fly.
If I can't fly, who gave him rights to fly?
What?
Can I get down from there?
I'm trying to feel like...
Oh, okay.
I'm trying to figure out where this would take me.
Okay.
Where does that take me?
Oh, it just takes me back.
How do I get up there?
I don't need that child anyway, nevermind.
We don't need that child.
Oh, no.
Not again.
That's not fair.
It's not fair.
Come on, get through that laser.
Nice.
What?
There's another one?
Oh, I missed.
Oh.
Nice.
I did it.
Wait, there's more?
This is not fair.
I didn't consent.
What hit me?
What?
It exploded in my fucking hands?
What the fuck hit me?
Like, what?
I don't understand.
How did that happen?
Like, I got a heart attack?
How the fuck did that hit me?
I'm just running.
Fuck this.
I'm running, but I'll kill that one guy because I hate him.
Oh my god, no.
Oops, yeah.
Okay.
That worked.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Come here!
Not fair!
Oh my god, what?
What?
I got combo'd!
That should be legal!
Comboing is not allowed.
What?
Everybody's out to get me.
I hit and swing and died.
Okay.
I know how to get there fast.
Guys, I'm not throwing.
It's just, they did illegal stuff.
I'm not throwing.
They did an illegal move.
It was illegal, I swear to god.
I refuse to believe it.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I almost forgot to do the one most important thing.
It's fine.
Fuck!
What?
He i-framed it?
He can do that?
What the fuck?
He literally i-framed it!
That's crazy.
I didn't even realize that is allowed.
Wait.
I remembered that.
The last time I did that, I almost killed myself.
Jesus Christ.
Oh my god, get out of here.
Get out of here.
I see you!
Get out of here!
God reads.
When did these guys know to i-frame?
Who gave them rights to do that?
They're not crows.
Shit.
Oh my god.
Boom.
How did I- Oh my god.
He ran into it.
I'm so stupid.
I accidentally rolled into the hammer.
I dodged the fucking magic to roll into it.
Oh my god.
I almost- I got killed by a grunt.
Oh, woe is me.
How far I've fallen, dying to a grunt.
I've fallen so far.
And then I miss.
There we go.
I didn't miss that, though.
What?
I don't want to run across.
Oh, it has range.
Okay.
Aww.
No.
Okay.
Okay, he doesn't know.
Okay, this is a little- Do I have children down?
I have children down there, I remembered.
I'm not doing this again, guys.
I have children down there.
I remember I planted seeds.
Where are the kids?
Kids, I know you exist.
Where are you?
There you go.
I refuse to run all the way back there.
I refuse.
Alright, nice.
I was not gonna do that.
I'm not a coward.
I'm just taking my fight strategically, guys.
It's all about strategy.
Okay, now I'm full HP again.
Okay.
That's actually- Okay, I'm gonna say it.
That was bullshit.
That was actually- What the fuck?
Mid-fuck- Mid-fucking hook, he fucking slaps me.
Okay.
I need to plant that.
I got hit mid-hook.
That doesn't seem so fair.
And I didn't realize how to get here.
Is that a hook?
I can.
What do I do over there?
Well, time to find out.
Where's this taking me?
Oh my god.
It took me back?
What?
Where am I?
Okay.
Okay, I- Okay.
Kids, I'm mad.
Follow me, kids.
I'm mad.
Follow me, children.
Croquis needs to take her anger out.
I'm not mad anymore.
No!
Fatherhood is so hard.
Croquis hates backtracking.
Okay, where's it here now?
Is this a slippy slide?
It is.
Okay, a slippy slide.
Oh my god.
Slippy slide.
Boom!
Oh god, not the slippy slide.
Alright.
I'm just gonna- Oh, he's crying like a bitch.
Okay, this way.
Okay.
Oh, fuck.
Oh, we have to be fast.
Oh!
Fast as fuck!
Jesus Christ!
Get back here!
I shall slide my way to victory!
Okay.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, fuck!
Oh
my god, I hate this.
I hate- Get me outta here!
Holy fuck.
They only give me eight souls!
Like, that's not- Oh god.
I almost died off.
They give me like, eight souls too, like the big boys.
That's crazy.
That is- If it takes me like, four Kamehamehas to fucking kill them, it should not take me eight- It should not give me eight souls.
Alright.
Off we go.
We unlock this area.
Okay.
Oh, this looks dangerous.
I have a feeling a lot of stuff are- Oh, there we go!
Yeah, it definitely- Yeah, that definitely looked dan- Oh wait, but they're little minions, so it should be fine.
Oh my god.
I didn't remember that I cannot Kamehameha like, next to them.
That's a stupid thing to do.
Okay.
Come on, get close to me!
Come on, get over here!
Jesus Christ.
Oh my god, I'm just sliding everywhere!
I- Where is it?!
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
Okay.
Okay, there we go.
Yeah!
Oh fuck, and I missed.
There's more?!
Oh!
Do you mean?!
Okay, I need to get the plants.
Okay.
Oh!
I keep forgetting physics!
I keep forgetting!
Why?!
Why does physics exist?!
This should be against all rules.
They're gonna follow me?!
Get outta here!
Okay.
I'm just gonna use my kamihalas.
I feel like-
What?!
Okay.
Okay, nice.
I'm just gonna be up here for a bit.
And then I'll beat this guy up.
Okay.
Okay, we got one of them.
Okay, let's get the other one.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Oh, I hate these little guys!
Get these little guys outta here!
Okay.
Get the plants first.
Why does physics not affect the plants?!
Not fair!
Oh shit.
Okay, it's fine.
He's too far away to get me.
Okay, he jumped closer.
It's not that far away anymore.
It's fine.
I got this.
Boom!
That's right!
I'm on top of- Oh, there's more?!
There's more?!
What do you mean?
What do you-
What do you mean by that?!
What do you mean there's more?!
Oh my god.
There's more!
Alright.
Oh my god, get up the stairs, please!
Please, for the love of god, get up the stairs!
Please!
My entire strategy relies on you to walk up the stairs!
They don't know how to walk up!
Alright.
Okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
Oh, fuck, that's not fine.
Woo!
Wait, wait, that's the stairs.
I almost- I almost used it on the fucking stairs.
Oh, that would've been so bad.
That actually would've been- No, no!
I almost slid into it!
I learned my lesson.
Not again.
Okay, there you go.
I didn't trust myself.
Oh my god, that was a lot.
I wish I had that plus one HP.
Wish I found that other shrine.
Guess not.
Rookie never learns.
Children.
Seaplant.
Consume.
Hello.
This is it!
That's the beast!
Oh boy, my heart is pounding!
Are you gonna fight it?
I'm gonna stay way out of the way and take notes for the song.
Good luck!
Okay, I'm ready.
I'm so ready.
After fighting all those little monsters, I think that shows I'm ready.
But he looks so nice.
Look, he smiled.
Look.
Betty.
Oh, her name's Betty!
He's not... Betty's not nice.
Betty's not nice.
Betty wants to kill.
Betty hungers.
Oh, Betty's hungers!
Oh, shit!
What the...
What the fuck?
How?
Oh my god, I don't know!
I don't know!
Oh!
Okay, I'm scared.
I'm actually scared.
She's so strong.
Oh!
I have to...
I think I just have to dodge whenever she runs.
Okay.
Oh my god, she throws snowballs too?
Oh!
Holy fuck!
I'm dead.
I'm so dead.
I'm so dead!
Oh my god!
She, like, bounces too, so I have to, like, do the double dodge.
Okay, that's, like, a moment I can actually...
I'm trying to, like, figure out when I can attack too.
What?
Oh!
No, I'm fucking dead.
There's no way.
Oh, what?
Wait, what?
That's it?
What?
That was the easiest first try!
How can Betty be the easiest?
Wait, what?
Betty was the easiest one of them all.
Well, we gathered here to mourn the passing of Betty.
To some, she was revered as a...
Wait, how are the free crows gonna get betting now?
How are they gonna...
Oh shit, the free crows are gonna...
are gonna freeze to death now.
To some, she was revered as a god.
To others, feared as a wild, untameable beast.
And to a small few, loved as a radiant...
Oh, wow, Steadhorn.
Wow.
After many lifetimes lived atop the mountain, so the...
Yeah, I was gonna say!
How are they gonna get the fur now?
Bow your head in remembrance, Betty.
Pay your last respects.
Our time in this world is over.
Oh my God, Stonehead, you freak.
You freak.
Oh, that's where all the crows...
These were the crow sacrifices.
Remember, demonic souls anger quelled Reaper.
May he find peace in death.
I did it!
You wanna make a sign?
Betty got booped.
Not so dead, but thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
What an incredible adventure this has been.
Full of twists and turns.
So Betty and the beast were one and the same?
Amazing!
That means the drunken guy that's trying to steal her, was he in love with the beast?
Whoa.
I kinda feel bad for both of them now.
Dead or heartbroken?
What you think?
Oh my God!
That guy at the drunken ceiling?
It was a fucking...
Wow!
He likes...
He likes big women.
They're both kinda tragic.
Still, it's great material for a song, huh?
I'm gonna write... start writing straight away.
I like him big.
I like him chunky.
I actually have the Madagascar...
Was it 3 or 2?
I don't remember.
It's Escape to Africa soundtrack.
Oh, it's 2.
I have the physical copy of the Madagascar 2 soundtrack.
And I have the full song of that...
What is it?
I like him big on my iPhone.
Sometime, and I'll play it for you.
Alright, nice.
I killed Betty.
I like him big.
I like him chunky, chunky.
Of course, she does.
Yeah, I used to be a soundtrack owner.
I buy, like, movie soundtracks all the time.
Back then, when I was a little bird.
I don't know why.
I would go to HMV and just buy soundtracks.
Can I upgrade?
Okay, I should get it.
Okay, we definitely need that.
Be gone, children.
And where do I go now?
Oh, back home.
I need to do the... I need to give the soul to them.
This way.
There has to be a faster door.
Maybe here?
Oh my god.
Don't tell me this is a faster way.
Wait, don't tell me this is a faster way.
Am I strong enough now?
No.
I'm not.
There has to be a faster way to get to the other side.
Now I'm making it slower though.
But I'm trying to figure it out.
Maybe this way?
Maybe here?
I'm definitely making it slower.
Yeah, okay.
Yeah, this is.
Okay, thank god.
This is another way to get there.
Fucking knew it.
Hello, children.
Daddy's gonna go come back in 10 days.
Don't worry.
He wouldn't have custody of you guys.
Hello, I got the last soul.
I did my job.
You did it.
You're a much stronger reaper than I.
I'm a child.
I was born like 5 days ago.
I would've never taken down those giant souls alone.
It is time.
Wait, I don't even have.
Is that pants?
Or just my feathers?
It is time at long last.
Let's force this door open and finish our assignment.
Wait, I don't even have pants!
Why do the free birds get to wear clothes?
Do I have?
I have less rights.
Wait, no, I do.
It is not fair!
Those are a prison.
Are they truly free if they're not naked?
You're right.
Door open!
And now to the other side.
Alright, here I go.
Man, you're old.
Oh my god, flashback.
Ahh!
This is it.
This is the place beyond where no life is to be seen.
Uh...
What?
That's it?
Who's that guy?
Is that the Reaper?
Is that Death?
Death!
What's up?
Wait, why does he have a fanny pack?
Are you Death?
I thought Tales of the Original Reaper was just the mad ramblings of the free crows.
Yeah, well, I guess that's me.
Fucking nerd!
So, if you didn't know I was real, that means you're not here to rescue me, huh?
Uh, no, I'm sorry.
We're here for another purpose.
In fact, you might- He's just a chill guy.
You might be able to help us.
Wow, rude!
But alright.
I mean, what's a few more minutes after several centuries?
So why are you here, actually?
How did you even get here?
Like, what- Wait, I should be more emo.
We seek souls that pass through Death's- Well, your door.
We're service-bound Reapers.
We're just contractors.
We require those souls to finish our task and restore our stature with a commission.
Otherwise, we will die.
Oh.
Awkward.
So like, if you're looking for a soul here, then you're out of luck.
Any non-Corpio soul that passes through the door are absorbed into the ether.
Soul energy has to be recycled to create new life.
That's why my job was so important.
Not the living didn't hate me for it.
So it's like, whatever.
It's like, I guess.
It's whatever.
I used to go around reaping souls myself.
Then pick them up and take them beyond the veil.
It was so depressing.
Like, that's not my vibe.
You get it, bro?
Not for the souls.
They don't care.
But for the lame-wit ones, they left behind.
I wish I could let them know dying isn't scary.
It's just a cycle of life or whatever.
Thing is, over the vastness of time, I got very tired of that cycle.
Then one day, a strange being came to me with a proposition, bro.
That being could like, create portals pretty rad.
Doors to any place or world.
They offered to outsource the collection of souls to an automated system using one of their doors or something.
I don't know.
While it was open, it would draw in the souls of the dead.
A lighthouse in the shores of the ether, if you will.
In return for this, they asked for their lives to be extended.
So I was like, whatever, cool.
Well, actually, they like, they asked for like, immortality?
But like, that's impossible.
The souls stick around too long past their expiration date.
They have nothing left to tie to mortality.
They came to some sort of demonic form or something?
But I don't fucking know.
All life must end.
Well, eventually, bro.
So, that kicked back several generations of these like, self-proclaimed lord of doors came and went.
Enjoying their unnaturally long lives.
Each one agreeing in the end to submit to the limitations of life and go into the ether or something.
I don't know.
Until one didn't.
Which is pretty fucking weird if you ask me.
But like, who cares?
Which brings us to your current lord of doors.
Towards the end of what should have been their lifestyle, bro, your lord betrayed our long-standing agreement and that was not cool.
That was not chill, man.
They said there had been some kind of incident.
That the door had malfunctioned and needed to be remade new.
For the door to be reconstructed, it required a touch of death to link to the door to the ether.
Totally uncool, bro.
So I like went there, you know?
But
after this new door was created and opened, the lord kicked me on the side and sealed it shut.
Totally not rad.
No way for me to escape.
No way for stray souls to pass on to the ether.
Like, no death among the living.
Not cool, bro.
He looks like that.
You're like, what kind of voice acting is that?
Like, look at him!
Major bummer, man.
I've been here alone ever since.
Wasn't chill, bro.
He's literally wearing a hoodie that's just a chill bro.
But, my soulless soul, it must be here.
It has to be here.
Attracted to this door.
It must have entered here somehow.
Are you sure you haven't seen it?
Sorry, guy.
If a soul comes here without body, it disappears into the ether.
Sooner or later, everything that begins has to end, bro.
So, there's no hope.
It must still be here somewhere.
No, no, no, no, no!
I wasted so many years searching for that soul.
Decades!
Oh my god, centuries.
You fucking live long.
We have a long lifespan.
I refuse to die.
Uh oh.
Bro, your friend cool, man?
Is your friend cool?
Does he need like, you know...
Does he need help?
I sense you're a little bit past your before date.
Best before date.
Oh shit!
He's going!
Oh!
He's going feral!
Oh my god!
Bro!
See ya.
Peace.
What the fuck?
He literally went peace.
Oh shit!
What the fuck?
Oh!
What?
Holy shit!
Okay, that's funny though.
I like how the...
I...
That's funny that he literally went peace, bro.
Oh my god!
Jesus Christ!
Okay, this guy's fucking freaky.
Whoa!
Oh my god, he's freaky!
It went feral!
It's going feral!
Oh!
What the fuck?
That's not fair!
That's actually not fair!
Bro, he's literally dead!
What do you mean you ain't fighting that?
Death.
You're on your own, bro.
Yeah, I'll try.
Okay.
Bro, what the fuck?
Like, what the...
He just...
He just runs me over!
Bro!
What to do when he runs you over?
Oh, okay.
I forgot he could...
You know, I'll do it again.
Just hit me.
That was not a good run.
That was...
That was 11 out of fighting.
Okay.
Okay, like, I learned now.
I figured it out.
Okay.
I had to figure things out, guys.
I'm just gonna use the Kamehameha.
The...
Oh my god!
Like, the...
The bomb takes too long to charge.
And I did not put in dexterity.
Jesus Christ!
I didn't remember.
I cannot...
Actually... Oh my god.
I don't know.
I'm trying to figure it out.
Because I can't do anything.
I guess, like, I'll fight him when he... Oh, I fight him when he...
when he caws.
Okay.
Because I'm like, how do I...
When he, like, moves...
I need to fight him when he starts cawing.
Jesus.
Okay.
Or when he does that, I guess.
Oh my god.
Oh!
Sometimes I don't know when he caws!
When caw!
Oh shit, I fucked it up.
Where is my body?
What?
Jesus Christ!
Sometimes I don't know when he caws!
It's not fair!
Okay, this is a hard...
This is a hard battle.
This is absolutely a hard battle.
What?!
This is not fair.
Oh, this is not fair.
Oh!
Oh my god, I can't...
I can't believe I missed that.
What does that do?
Oh, it sucks!
It's a sucker!
What the fuck?
Why are there many crows?
Oh!
Shit!
Oh my god.
Oh, it slows me...
Oh, it slows me down!
Okay, now I know.
I was like so confused.
I was like, what is it doing?
Okay.
Oh my god!
Get away from me!
We're one of the same!
Jesus Christ.
Oh!
Get away!
Oh my god.
This crow fight.
Too many crows!
Oh!
Okay.
Jesus Christ.
Don't you hate it when there's just too many!
Oh, he's dead.
Okay.
Goodbye.
Never go full crow, guys.
Bro, I can't tell you how lucky I am.
I don't know how long it's been since I felt a fresh breeze on my face.
Or like, saw well or anything.
Never appreciate something until it's gone, do you?
Is this the orphan of cause?
Thank you for the super chat burrito.
Thank you, thank you.
So long, Emma John.
But, until your lord of doors locked me up, Never thought it'd apply to me.
Sorry about your big feather friend back there.
It's always hard for the living to let go of the dead or something.
I don't know.
He wasn't pretty chill, though.
He was not chill at all.
Even more of a rough one.
Having to reap him yourself.
Seems like a bummer, bro.
I sort of understand that feeling.
Even if it was your intention, You've done me a huge favor here, crow.
But, This isn't over quite yet.
Because while the door has been destroyed, My power is unfortunately still trapped in its remains.
Forging a door requires a piece of my own soul.
And I need it back before I can do my job again.
That means...
Golly heinous, man.
I know.
If we want to end this cycle, Someone else has to take down the lord of the doors.
Have you guessed who yet?
Starts with a C.
I won't be making any more deals, that's for sure.
Head back to your office and reap your boss's soul, crow.
Or like, I don't know, something similar.
And remember, Death is on your side.
Bro, you peaced out!
What the fuck?
Bro!
I saw you peaced out!
Oh my god.
It's time.
Revolution!
No more!
I shall be a free bird!
Viva la revolution!
Do you hear the crows sing?
Na na na!
No crow!
No more masters for crows!
Crow free bird!
Off with his head!
For the crow pup!
Okay, we gotta go head home.
Wherever that is.
I'm so lost.
Oh, there's the door.
That's right.
My people!
I've seen a new world!
That's what I was about to do!
My fellow crows!
There is a world beyond work!
We have arrived at a moment foretold long ago.
Today, death's door has been opened and death is down with down with Corpo!
And death themselves has been freed once more into the world!
Down with the lords!
Fear not!
For this is not the end of days!
But beginning of a bright new future!
Viva la revolution!
The forces of life and death have been unnaturally thrown into chaos for a thousand years!
And we crows played a hand in that!
We must right our wrongs!
We must accept our fate!
We must reject those who lead us into the future with no hope!
It's time for the Lord of Doors' reign to end!
And for us to return to a light, natural life cycle!
Even as our world teeters on the edge of oblivion, souls like these four spirits still manage to emerge through the cracks.
Soon a new age will begin and the world will teem with new life!
Viva la revolution!
For that to happen, the final hours of this foretold day must play out as ordained!
The crow that freed death will have to end the Lord of Doors' reign!
For the crows!
Viva la crovulation!
Yes, I'd like to increase my combat, please.
Okay, we'll do...
We'll do...
Oh my God, I feel like...
Okay, we'll do magic.
I don't need to be that fast.
I know that you'll complete your task, old friend.
Have faith in yourself.
We're gonna do it, guys!
Stop working!
I hope I can find a new...
No!
We are free birds!
We don't need jobs!
The feel of keys on my feathers.
You can just write a book or something!
You don't need a job for that!
The clicking and clacking as I push them down.
Look at me getting carried away.
Just write a book!
Go on.
You best finish cleaning this up.
I have a resume to write.
So I guess we're all gonna be out of our jobs soon.
Finally can free-free of the rat race.
Be free!
I never wanted to be a reaper, you know.
It was just a matter of necessity.
I wonder what I could do next.
I guess endless possibilities lies ahead.
Cause that depends on you finishing your job without getting killed in the process.
But I reckon you'll get it done, kid.
Aren't you guys gonna help?
Like, a revolution is not one per- Guys!
There's so many of us!
Why is it just me?
A revolution is not one crow!
All this death and rebirth is no help.
It is a daunting prospect.
I think everyone here is sick of what this world has become.
A new world.
A new start.
I wonder if there will be new TV shows too.
What about you?
I feel like my whole world is crumbling beneath my feet.
But somehow, no jobs just open a crumbly fence.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
But somehow, I also feel hopeful for the first time.
Actually, I think this is the first time I felt hope.
Maybe I won't have to work so hard anymore.
Let's go.
A revolution is upon us.
We go up now.
Get away, kids.
Adults only.
Alright, it's time to open the big door.
I am here now.
That's right.
I am here for the big man.
You thought you could live forever?
Nobody lives forever.
I've been watching you, young crow.
Oh, me?
I never thought I would come to this.
Yet, here we are.
Each of my kind are created by the Lord preceding them and trained to take over their duties before they pass on.
On the day we are created, we are told the day on which we will die.
My predecessor, my creator, was a cold-hearted tyrant.
Obsessed with rules and order, how things had to be.
That old fool never even gave me a name, can you believe?
You can give yourself a name.
You're a free man.
How would your life play out if you knew the exact day you were going to die?
If every moment of your existence revolved around its ending, I'd do everything in my power to save myself.
I know my actions are not entirely moral, perhaps not even justifiable.
But I cannot just let myself die.
I refuse to go without a fight.
So, young crow, are you ready to fight for your life as I am for mine?
Alright.
Oh my god.
What the fuck?
He just slams.
Spirit bomb!
Okay.
That all he does?
Oh my god.
Okay.
Guys, I- Man, I wish like, you know.
Oh wait, that's not all he does.
Oh my god!
Oh my god.
He's using the doors against me.
What the fuck?
Where'd he go?
He went to another door?
What the fuck?
Where'd he go?
Oh shit!
It's this type of game!
How do I get across?
Hello?
Oh.
Okay.
I use my mechanics.
Okay, I figured it out.
Oh!
No!
It's okay.
I can make one mistake.
Wait, what?
Okay, goodbye.
Another door.
Oh!
Oh my god, he slaps, guys.
I learned.
I realized.
He slaps back.
Okay, guys, I should've got dexterity.
I- Guys!
I think- I should've got dexterity, guys.
I think I made a mistake.
Who would've thought?
Maybe I should not have- Maybe I should not have- What?!
Okay.
This is bullshit.
Okay, I- This level is- This level is a little hard.
I'm also a little stupid.
Oh no, I'm 1 HP.
Oh no, this is bad.
This is- This is- This is pretty bad.
This is pretty bad.
Okay.
I ran into it!
Okay, I understand!
I understand!
Okay.
Oh shit, nice.
I figured it out.
I don't get punished that badly, at least.
I figured it out, guys.
I'm not as stupid.
Okay, there we go.
I figured it out.
I just- I need to do so many dodging.
Okay, I need to go so fast.
So it's scary.
Wait, does he keep his damage from before though?
Okay, I need to use the Kamehameha.
Because I- Oh!
I missed!
Oh!
Okay.
I have to be not too- I have to- Are you serious?!
That doesn't give me i- I should've got i-frames for that.
That should've been- That should've been i-frames right there.
That should 100% give me i-frames.
The i-frame sometimes is like, so confusing.
Because it's like, I don't know when it's gonna do it.
You know?
It's like, when is it gonna give me those frames?
Of course I want one second of i-frames.
What the fuck?
Okay, Kamehameha.
Oh shit, I missed the portal.
Boom.
Oh!
Ah!
No!
Oh!
I'm like, I'm fucking panicking.
I'm panicking when he does that.
Oh yeah.
Oh!
Oh my god!
He almost slapped me!
He almost slapped me, that freak!
Where am I?
I don't know this area!
Oh no, I have to go fast.
Oh!
Oh, I have to go so fast!
Jesus Christ, these mechanics!
Oh no, what is he gonna do now?
Oh!
No!
It's so fast!
Oh, please.
How far am I?
Ah!
I had to do it all from the beginning!
Ah, you fucking freak!
Oh, I almost ran into it.
I had to go all the way?
Oh!
Okay.
Okay, I figured it out though.
Okay, I know what to do.
Okay.
Okay, this boss fight is actually pretty intense.
Three hits.
Three hits!
Okay.
What if I just use the arrows?
I'll use arrows.
Because arrows are faster.
Oh!
Okay.
Nice!
Okay, I'll just use arrows.
I'll just use arrows, they're faster.
Okay, first part.
Done!
Okay.
Okay, this fight is actually very intense, guys.
I think this is a really- I like the design of this boss fight.
But it's very...
scary.
Oh!
Oh my god.
First part figured out!
Downloaded!
Alright, arrows the key.
Guys, why didn't you guys...
selectively tell me...
to get dexterity?
Okay.
Oh!
I dodged it!
That was totally a dodge!
That was totally a dodge.
I refuse to believe that wasn't a dodge.
I can't believe it.
I refuse to believe it.
Not my fucking dodge.
Okay.
Ah!
No, no, no, no, no, no!
Oh my god, I almost rolled off!
I almost rolled off!
Okay.
I gotta be very careful with this one.
I...
I was like on the edge.
That was so close.
Oh, I don't not...
This is scary.
Oh my god!
Okay.
Oh my god.
He's almost broken.
He's so close!
God, that roll is so...
There's more?
Oh no.
Okay.
Jesus Christ!
We made it!
Where are we?
We're full HP!
Oh thank god!
Wait.
That was all a distraction?
What happened?
What?
Wait, he's full HP!
Why are we here, crew?
Why do I exist?
To follow in the footsteps of the lords before me?
To repeat the same thing over and over to what end?
What is the point?
Where are the crews?
And we all have to die eventually.
I suppose I will never know.
Because I will never die!
What are you doing?
The last lord.
Wait, did I not?
What do you mean?
What happened to all the progress I did before?
Why is he so much bigger?
Oh my!
What was that?
What the fuck?
What?
Guys, I don't think I'm gonna live.
Guys.
This ain't looking so good for Doki Croki.
This ain't looking so good right now.
Holy shit!
Okay.
Oh my god.
Hello, I woke up.
It's fine.
Round two.
Round two, I guess.
What do I do?
Against that?
Oh no.
Oh, I don't like this one.
Oh my god!
The stupid fuzz!
Stupid!
How do I get out of that?
I don't understand.
My brain can't comprehend.
It can't comprehend it!
Brain too stupid!
I... fuck you!
The backhand!
I'm too greedy.
I'm too...
I need to...
I need to not be so greedy.
Okay.
Don't be greedy.
Don't let him do that to you.
Oh shit!
Sorry, I got confused.
I hate this one the most.
I...
I... oh my god!
It's so hard to dodge!
It's actually so hard!
Jesus!
Don't get greedy.
Okay, okay, I know.
Just let him mash it.
Okay.
How does that hit me?!
That should not have hit me.
That actually should...
Ah!
Okay, okay.
Every try, every try I get better.
Every try.
Oh!
Okay.
He's gonna do a backhand there.
If he wanted to.
I could tell.
Oh my god!
I jumped into that, I'm so dumb.
I'm so dumb!
Crookies!
Dumb!
Okay.
Do a circle, okay.
A pose!
Just end me!
I hate the lasers!
Okay.
I hate the lasers so much.
The lasers are so stupid.
Why did that...
End this.
I already fucked it up.
Why you prolong my suffering?
Why you prolong it?
End this.
Oh my... Okay, this time, this time.
This is it.
I walked into the last one.
It was my bad.
It was NB.
My bad.
Okay.
There we go.
Oh
my god.
That backhand is so scary sometimes.
Okay, I know he does that after...
The stupid...
What?!
Really?!
Okay.
That shouldn't have hit me earlier.
I'm so sad that that hit me.
Oh god.
I'm not gonna...
Play slow.
Okay.
No!
I was not trying to roll there too!
You stupid backshots!
You stupid...
Stupid fucking...
Backslap!
Jesus Christ.
Oh no.
No!
Oh my god.
Woo!
No!
Dodge!
I hate the back...
It's always the backslap.
It's always...
The fucking backslap that he does.
Okay.
Don't get backslapped.
No, they are.
They're so fucking...
Fucking hard.
No!
They're so hard to deal with sometimes.
I'm trying so hard to like...
Calculate when he does that.
Woo!
Okay.
Oh!
No!
Jesus Christ.
What?
I thought he was going to do a laser for some reason.
Okay, now he is.
God.
What?
There's more?
No!
The fucking...
Oh
my god.
Oh!
Backslap, I knew it.
Okay.
Oh!
No!
What is that?
What did he do?
I don't know what he did.
No, not the laser.
Oh, fuck.
Fuck.
Actually, the scariest one.
Oh!
I fucking did it!
Please.
Forgive me.
I'm going to backslap you.
Get over here.
I'm going to fucking slap you.
Oh my god.
Today, we're more in the passing of being.
We shape the very fabric of our world.
Viva la revolution!
The end of a lineage.
The last lord of doors.
The true cruel god.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
To some, they were a mysterious leader.
To others, a dark cloud looming over the world.
Driven by a desire to be greater than their creator.
They will be remembered for their part in the advancement of door technology.
Their ability to maintain order in a dying world.
And their unwavering determination to evade death.
No matter the cost.
We did it.
Viva la crovulation!
All with his head.
Their pursuits may have been unwise, but the will to live is deeply ingrained.
Who is to say what any of us would have done, given the same choices as this lord?
Bow your head in remembrance.
Pay your last respects.
Your time in this world is over.
Goodbye.
Home run.
Death's door.
We did it!
Oh my god!
We fucking did it!
That was fun!
I really enjoyed it.
I really enjoyed the game.
Oh my god.
There they are.
Wait, they're all eating his parts.
No!
Stop!
Don't eat it!
Please!
It's a fetish thing!
Don't do it!
Oh my god!
It's been a while since we beat a game.
Since we've been stuck in our Dynasty Warriors series.
So I'm happy we're actually able to- It's been a long time.
Since we're able to finish this game.
Oh my god!
Me and my best friend parted!
And all the dragoons!
Look at that!
We're not hanging out with that fucking squid freak.
That was so fun!
I had a great time.
We're stuck in the dating sim hell.
Yeah, that should be the end of the game.
We're not doing the- We're not being completionist.
Thank you for the super chat, Adam!
Thank you, thank you!
Oh my god, look!
That's all of us!
Look at us go!
Is there a- Is there an after credits scene, guys?
Or is it just this?
Oh wait, I can make it faster.
But yeah, it was really fun!
I really enjoyed this game.
I went in accidentally thinking this was a roguelite.
And it was just Crow.
It was just- Oh, it was made in Unity.
It was just Crow Souls-like.
And I had a lot of fun playing it.
Oh.
There he is.
Oh, there's an after credits scene.
Yeah, it was a pretty chill game.
I enjoyed it a lot.
He's like...
Doki, doki.
This is not what I meant when I said I wanted a Souls-like.
But too bad.
We get Crow Souls-like.
Oh, I can still...
do so.
Yeah.
Nice, we did it!
We're free Crows!
Guys, we don't need to get jobs anymore!
Let's go!
We're free Crows!
Get out of here, children.
We're free- I said I'm a free Crow now.
I don't need to be a father no more.
Yeah.
I'm gonna live my life being free.
We're free!
We're no more jobs!
Let's go!
Yay!
Crows don't need the concept of money no more!
Being a parent is a lifelong job.
What the fuck are you talking about?
It never stops.
Oh my god.
I'm so happy.
It was really fun.
I definitely enjoyed it a lot.
I think this has been...
a game I normally don't really play often.
Like this type of genre.
So it was really nice to try it out.
I've been wanting to try this game out for a very long time.
So I'm glad...
I'm glad I actually found the time to actually try it.
Because I was like, oh, what game should I play?
What game should I play this time?
I always want to try out different games every so often.
But yeah!
It's nice going out of my comfort zone.
Sometimes.
But yeah, thank you everybody for watching!
I hope you guys enjoyed...
Death's Door.
My throat actually feels a lot better.
Recently.
I haven't been coughing at all when I'm streaming.
But I don't want to push it too far today.
But in the future streams, I'm going to try to do...
After stream chatting again.
But because I did a long stream today.
For 4 hours.
I'm going to chug a little bit.
Just to rest up a little bit.
But for future streams, I'm going to try to do after stream chatting again.
Just so...
Just because I can now.
Win!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Hey Doki, I just leveled up to 31 a couple of days ago.
I was wondering if I could get a late happy birthday shoutout.
Of course, Win!
Your streams always brighten my day.
And help me keep going.
Thanks for everything you do.
Also, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Winlines.
Yay!
Happy birthday!
Hey guys, before I go.
I'm going to do my show.
If you want croaky plush right now.
Croaky can't talk.
But I have croaky plushes out.
Also, old girl and tomato meme.
So, buy now.
You can purchase a croaky plush right now.
On YouTubes.
Let me grab the link real quick.
YouTube slash collection slash Doki Bear.
Also, I need to walk dad too.
That's why I can't do more after stream chatting.
Because I need to walk him.
So, he's actually here right now.
He's like, it's time.
It's time for walkies, isn't it?
I know that shill voice.
Every time you try to shill.
It's walkies time.
So, I gotta walk him now.
Hey guys, thank you all for coming.
As always everybody.
Stay hydrated.
Get that plush look.
And if you stay up for me.
Head to bed.
Because you deserve it.
See you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys.
Sorry, he knows it's walkies time.
Bye bye.